hey everyone welcome to yet another
exciting video from simply learn in this
session we will be learning about data
structures
this particular tutorial is based on
data structures part one
so before we get started let me tell you
guys that we have daily updates on
multiple technologies if you're a tech
geek in a continuous hunt for latest
technological trends then consider
getting subscribed to our youtube
channel and don't forget to hit that
bell icon to never miss an update from
simply learn so without further ado
let's get started with our agenda for
today's session
so this particular data structures part
one will be covering the following
things first we will learn the
fundamentals of an algorithm followed by
that we will learn what are data
structures
after understanding the fundamentals of
algorithms and data structures we will
go through the road map for a better
understanding followed by that we will
understand the complexities of
algorithms
and after finishing the basics we will
get started with our first data
structure that is pointers followed by
pointers we will learn arrays in iris we
will learn the single dimensional arrays
first followed by that we will go into
the multi-dimensional arrays once we are
finished with arrays we will head into
linked lists in linked list we will
learn singly linked list doubly linked
list and circular linked lists once we
are done with linked list we will have a
comparison between arrays and linked
lists followed by the comparison we will
learn stack data structure and after
learning stacks we will try to implement
stack data structure using arri followed
by that we will try to implement stack
data structure also using linked lists
once we are done with stack data
structure we will move into queues we
will learn the fundamentals of queues
then we will try to implement q using an
array data structure followed by that we
will try to implement q using linked
list data structure
next we will learn priority queue and dq
later we will try to compare stacks and
queue data structures then we will start
learning our searching algorithms the
first one would be our linear search and
the next parts will be continued in the
part two so i hope i made myself clear
with the agenda now let's get started
with our first topic that is what is an
algorithm
so how does algorithm work in real life
so we'll have a use case here
on my screen we have a lady and she is
shreya shreya wants to make some tea and
for that she is following some steps
so the first step is she'll take a pan
and fill it with water and place it on a
gas tub
followed by that the second step is
she'll make sure that the water comes to
a nice boil and then she adds some tea
leaves and sugar
followed by step 2 we have step 3 where
she'll allow the leaf to be fully
expanded and she'll add some milk after
that
next we have the stefo where she will
wait for the tea to come for a good
decent boil
next we have step 5 where she'll turn
off the gas and she'll take the pan off
from the stove and the tea is ready to
get filtered and lastly we have the step
6 where she is all set with the tea
so in computer science an algorithm is a
method or set of rules that we must be
following to perform some specific
calculations or other problem solving
operations
as a result an algorithm is a collection
of rules or instructions that govern how
a work needs to be conducted step by
step to achieve the desired results
to accomplish a task
we first provide some input and then
follow a sequence of steps to acquire
the required outcome of the input so
that is the fundamental definition of an
algorithm and we also had a use case
and now we will move ahead and
understand the characteristics of
algorithms
so basically we have six characteristics
of algorithm
so the first one is it should be clear
and unambiguous the second one is that
it has to be well defined inputs and the
third one is that it has to be
having well-defined outputs as well the
fourth property of an algorithm is its
feasibility followed by that
finiteness and finally we have language
independence
now we will look into each one of the
characteristics in detail so first we
have clear and unambiguous
so this statement is the one which
states that the algorithm should be
straightforward simple and easily
readable
each one of its steps should be distinct
in every way and lead it to a single
conclusion
so the next one is it should be having
well-defined inputs so this means that
an algorithm should indicate what output
can be expected as well as the input
should be properly well-defined now we
have the third one similarly we should
also have well-defined outputs so the
well-defined output characteristics of
an algorithm means that the algorithm
must clearly indicate what output can be
expected as well as the output should
also be well defined followed by the
third characteristic we have the fourth
characteristic that has the finiteness
of algorithm so the finiteness of
algorithm says that the algorithm must
be finite and it must not result in
infinite loops or similar situations
so followed by the fourth one we have
the fifth characteristic that defines
about the feasibility of an algorithm
so feasibility of an algorithm states
that the algorithm must be really simple
generic and practical
it must be able to be executed with
resources available
now the last characteristic of the
algorithm is being independent of the
language
so it means that the algorithm should be
defined in such a way that it is
completely independent of the language
it must be simple instructions that can
be implemented using any programming
language
so these were the six major
characteristics of algorithm now let's
move ahead and understand how to write
an algorithm
writing an algorithm does not have any
hard and fast rules
next algorithms are never created to
support a specific programming language
as we all know algorithm should be
capable enough to support the
conditional statements such as if if
else switch etc
an algorithm should be capable enough to
execute some of the conditional
statements such as if if else switch etc
and also it must be capable to execute
the iterative statements such as for
loop while loop do while loop etc
we usually create algorithms in a
step-by-step manner however this isn't
always the case
after the problem domain has been well
defined algorithm writing is a procedure
that is carried out
we build an algorithm to find a solution
to a problem a problem can be resolved
in a variety of ways let's look at an
example of how to write an algorithm
consider the following scenario we need
to create an algorithm to determine the
largest number among the three given
numbers x y and z as a result the
initial solution to the problem can be
written in this manner
so we begin with reading all the three
numbers and in the second step we will
have a condition that says if x is
greater than y we will proceed to step
four else we will proceed to step five
next in step four we establish a
condition that if x is greater than z
then x is the largest of the three
numbers otherwise z is the largest
if y is greater than z z will be the
greatest number otherwise y will be the
largest number amongst all the three in
step five
and the procedure will be terminated
let's have a look at what the next
solution has to offer in this algorithm
we begin by reading all the three
variables then compare all the three
numbers in the third step to determine
the largest number which is if x is
greater than y then there is another if
else statement that states that if x is
greater than y then x is largest
otherwise z is the largest
then there's if else statement which
says that if y is greater than z then y
is greater otherwise z is the greatest
of the three numbers so this is how we
have multiple solutions to the same
problem so after discussing these
solutions we will move ahead and
understand algorithm analysis
the algorithm may be studied in two
levels first before it is made and then
after it is created the two analysis of
an algorithm are as follows the first
one is priori analysis and the second
one is the post analysis so first we
will talk about the priori analysis
priori analysis refers to the
theoretical analysis of an algorithm
performed before its implementation
before implementing the algorithm other
parameters such as processor speed might
be considered which does not affect the
implementation component next we will
talk about post analysis
a practical analysis of an algorithm is
called as posterior analysis and it
utilizes any computer language to build
the algorithm the purpose of this
analysis is to determine how much time
and space the algorithm takes to operate
now after being understood the algorithm
analysis we will be able to comprehend
the algorithm complexity two methods can
be used to assess the algorithm
complexity the first one is time
complexity which states that the amount
of time required to finish an
algorithm's execution is known as its
time complexity
followed by time complexity the other
one is the space complexity which is
calculated by the quantity of space
required to solve a problem and produce
an output of space complexity of an
algorithm
let's take a closer look at these
complexities
now we will begin with
time complexity of an algorithm the big
o notation is used to express an
algorithm's time complexity the
asymptomatic notation is used to depict
temporary complexity of big o notation
the time complexity is mainly determined
by counting the number of steps required
to complete the task
let's take a look at an example to
understand this time complexity in a
much better way
if we want to find out multiplication of
n numbers we can do it by executing a
loop from 1 to n then calculating
multiplication when the loop ends then
multiplication holds the n numbers
multiplication and last we return the
calculated multiplication
the loop statements time complexity will
be at least n and when the number of n
increases the time complexity will also
increase
while the code's complexity that is
returns multiplication will remain
constant because its value is unaffected
by the value of n and it will obtain the
result in every single step
next we will discuss about space
complexity which is expressed with big o
notation just as time complexity
these four items are stored in space
complexity it initially saves program
instructions then stores constant values
then stores variable values and finally
it keeps track of function cells jumping
statements and so on
the sum of auxiliary space and input
size is used to calculate space
complexity the extra space or temporary
space used by an algorithm is referred
to an auxiliary space after learning
about algorithm complexity we will look
at some of the algorithms pros and cons
so let's start with the advantages of
algorithms firstly algorithms are easy
to understand
next algorithms are step-by-step
representation of a solution and lastly
the problem is broken down into smaller
bits or steps in an algorithm making it
easier for the programmer now an
algorithm also have various drawbacks
one of which being it takes long time to
write hence it is time consuming second
con of the algorithm is algorithms make
it harder to demonstrate branching and
looping statements
so followed by the advantages and
disadvantages of algorithms we now enter
into the final segment where we discuss
the differences between algorithms and
programming so the first difference is
that
an algorithm is a type of programming on
the other hand a program is more
directly associated with the computer
performing one or more tasks but an
algorithm is more of a notation a
technique for solving a problem
now let us discuss the second difference
an algorithm can be decoded or run by a
human whereas the program is only run or
decoded by a set of compilers of the
computer
now the third difference
basically an algorithm is a design of
the solution to the problem
here we can only analyze the solution
but we can never run it
but whereas on the other hand
programming is completely a different
ballgame here you can directly implement
a certain phase or an entire program and
test the programs and get an output
so the fourth and the last difference
between an algorithm and programming is
an algorithm is written using natural
human vocabulary whereas programs are
written using any programming language
such as c c plus plus java python etc
now let's get started with our first
concept that is what are data structures
data is an information that has been
translated into a form that is efficient
to movement or processing in computing
as it relates to trades computers and
transmission media data is an
information that has been converted into
binary digital form the term raw data
refers to the data in its most basic
digital format after defining data let's
look at what data structure entails a
data structure is a data organization
management and storage format in
computer science that allows for
efficient access and modification or a
data structure is an algebraic structure
about data that contains a collection of
data values their relationships and
their functions or operations
that can be applied to the data
we will now understand why exactly we
need data structures now that we have
already defined what is a data structure
so let us have a look at some of the
data structure characteristics the first
one is each data structure allows data
to be stored differently following that
the data structure allows for more
efficient data search and retrieval then
specific data structures are chosen to
solve specific problems last but not the
least it enables the management of large
amounts of data such as large databases
and indexing services such as hash
tables
let us now look at some real-world
examples of data structures
first and the foremost we have the
dictionary assume that we're looking for
the word simply learn in the dictionary
and we know it begins with the letter s
so we can search for this word beginning
with the letter s and then this is an
example of array data structure as a
result this dictionary can also function
like an array data structure
following by that we have a music player
example
if you have a playlist with three songs
the second song will play after the
first and the third will play after the
second so these will be played without
any interruption because all these three
songs are linked with each other using
linked list type of data structure so
followed by linked list the next example
we have is the data structures
the stack of books analogy is a perfect
example of the real-time working of the
stack data structure subsequent to that
assume there is a line of people at a
ticket window and the person who comes
first gets the ticket
this particular movie window queue is an
example for the real-time implementation
of queue data structure
last but not the least google maps
google map is the graph data structure
in which all the cities and states are
connected if we want to go from one
place to another there may be many ways
to do so so we can use some algorithms
to find the shortest path
as a result the google map is a perfect
example for the graph data structure
working analogy
following that we will look at some
different types of data structures in
this tutorial
so the first type is the linear data
structure
the elements in the linear data
structure are arranged subsequently one
after the other they are simple to
implement because the elements are
arranged in specific order
followed by the first type the second
type is the non-linear data structure
which we will be discussing a bit later
so in linear data structures we have
four different types the first one is
the array data structure memory elements
are arranged in a continuous order in
arrays
and arrays elements are of same type the
software program also determines the
type of elements that can be stored in
arrays so followed by arrays we have
linked list linked lists are completely
similar to data structures data elements
in linked list data structure are linked
together by a series of nodes
furthermore each node contains the data
items as well as the address to the next
node
the third data structure is the stack
data structure elements in a stack data
structure are stored using lifo
principle in other words the last
element stored in the stack is remote
first in stack operations can only be
performed in one end
namely the top
and the last data structure is the queue
data structure
unlike stack queue data structure
operates in the fifo principle which
states that the first element stored in
the queue is remote first in a queue
insertion and deletion are carried out
from opposite ends now we will discuss
the second type of data structures which
are the non-linear data structures
the non-linear data structure is the
second type of data structure non-linear
data structures do not have elements in
any order as opposed to the linear data
structures instead they are arranged in
hierarchical order with one element
connected to one or more others
so the first one in the non-linear data
structures is the tree data structure a
tree data structure is built using nodes
and edges each element in the tree data
structure is called as node or vertex
each vertex or node is connected to the
other nodes or other vertices using
edges
and the second one in the list is the
graph data structure
a graph data structure is completely
like a tree data structure
it also has the vertices and edges each
vertex in a graph data structure is
connected using edges the only
difference between a tree and graph is
that in entry you can have n number of
vertices but in graph you will have only
two vertices
after discussing the graph data
structure we will move ahead into the
last segment of this tutorial that has
importance of data structures so the
first one data structures are widely
used in almost every aspect of computer
science both for simple and complex
computations
next data structures are used in all
areas of computer science including
artificial intelligence graphics big
data operating systems and much more
after that the data structures are an
essential component of many computer
algorithms because they allow
programmers to manage data efficiently
lastly a proper data structure of
selection can improve the efficiency of
a computer program or algorithm
there are various programming languages
that you can learn to help your code
data structures
we will discuss c language
c plus
python
and java
let's discuss them in detail
first up c language
c is a general purpose structure
programming language
c language can be used to develop
programs like operating systems
compilers
databases and so on
c language has a vast library that
contains numerous built-in functions
next up c plus plus language
c plus plus is also a general purpose
programming language
c plus plus supports seven styles of
programming
like functional
structural and object-oriented
programming
is also used in creating operating
systems browsers and games etc
next up python programming
python is the most significant
programming language because the syntax
of python programming can be easy to
understand to every learner's level
and this programming language is also
loaded with the full of libraries that
helps in implementing scientific
computing
working and deployment of python are
supportive and easy in any environment
finally java programming language
in this modern era java is the best
language to choose
nearly thousands of applications
softwares and development tools are
built using the java programming
language
the technology is primarily used in
creating websites such as youtube google
amazon flipkart and many more
moving forward now that you have a
better understanding of which
programming languages you would like to
code with let's understand what are the
prerequisites you need to learn to get
started with the data structures and
algorithms
first up basic syntax
before you start writing any code you
need to have basic syntax on your tips
or
you may run into various errors
next up
data types
if you want to make your code perform
various operations and you will need to
understand data types
and their syntax
next up operators variables and
functions
these are the elements that makes a code
functional or operational
data types are essential in declaring
them
next up conditional statements or loops
let's say if we want to print only a
specific part of the information when
certain conditions are met then we can
write conditional statements if else if
we were going to print a lot of elements
like all natural numbers from 1 200
with a bit of code
then we can write some loops like for
loop or while loop
then we will discuss object oriented
programming
object oriented programming or oops is
built around objects which are data
structures that contains both data
and the code
next up we will discuss data structures
we will start with arrays
linked list
stack
queues
trees
graphs
and heaps
now let's have a closer look at them
first up
arrays
an array is collection of elements
stored in consecutive memories
an array is the most basic data
structures
the majority of data structure and
algorithms can be implemented with the
help of arrays
next up is linked list
a linked list is the linear data
structures made of nodes
these nodes are made up of two parts
data and the address to the next node
link lists are easier to work with and
they are faster at insertion and
deletion
next up stacks
stack is a linear data structure that
follows a particular order from which
the operations are performed we can
perform insertion and deletion only from
the top this is also why stacks are
called
lasting first out or lifo based data
structures
in stack insertion is referred to as
push operation and deletion as pop
operation
next up cues
cues is also an abstract data structures
but unlike stakes a cue is open at both
its end
one end is used for insertion
also referred to as nq
and the other is used for deletion also
known as dq
this is why the queue is regarded as
first in first out or fifo based data
structure
following trees
a tree is a hierarchical data structures
made up of nodes
the first node of the tree or the node
which has no parents is called root node
else all of the other nodes can have a
maximum of one parent and can have
multiple childrens
each node contains some data and links
to its children's
next up graph
a graph is a non-linear data structure
consists of nodes and edges
the nodes are sometimes also referred to
as vertices
and the edges are lines and arcs that
connects any of the two nodes
graphs are often used to represent
networks
finally
heap
a heap is a special case of
trees heap is a complete binary tree
that is it can have maximum of two
children and all level except for the
last level should be filled
a he is of two types
max heap and min heap
when every node has a value greater than
its parent then the heap is called max
heap
and when every node in a heap has less
value than its parent then that t is
called min here
now that you have firm grasp of basic
coding and data structures we will
discuss some algorithms
we will first discuss
searching and sorting
after that we will discuss divide and
conquer
then greedy algorithm
dynamic programming
and backtracking
let's discuss them in detail
first up searching
searching algorithms are intended to
search and retrieve an element
from any data structure in which it is
stored
next
a sorting algorithm is used to rearrange
the elements of an array a list based on
the comparison operator on the element
efficient sorting is critical for
enhancing the efficiency of other
algorithm that needs input to be sorted
list
next up divide and conquer
this algorithm requires to divide the
whole problem into sub problems and
solve them and then combine them back to
get a complete solution
some algorithms follow this approach
like quick sort merge sort and stances
algorithm
divide and conquer requires that there
must be more than two sub-problems
next is greedy approach
the greedy algorithm aims to build up a
solution by selecting the most
beneficial option
greedy is best suited to problems when
picking the locally optimal also leads
to a global solution
the greedy can also be used to solve
huffman coding
job sequencing and knapsack problems
next up dynamic programming
a dynamic programming technique that
produces smaller sub problems and then
uses the sub problem solutions to solve
the more significant problem
dynamic programming is nothing but
optimization of recursion problems
simple optimization can change the time
complexity from
exponential to polynomial
next up
backtracking
backtracking is an algorithmic approach
to recursively solving problems by
attempting to develop a solution
progressively
one piece at a time
then discarding any solution that do not
fulfill the problems criteria at any
point in time
backtracking is also used to solve
problems like end queens suroku
hamiltonian cycle etc
we have now discussed both data
structures and algorithms
now let's have a look at top coding
contest or platforms to hone your skills
we will start with hacker rank
then code beta
geeks coding challenge
code jam and at last code chef
let's discuss them in detail
first up hacker rank
hacker rank is a technology hiring
platform that is standard for assessing
developer skills
hacker rank organizes various contacts
like aha rank hack fest and hack the
interview
next up code vita code vita is coding
platform where one can compete against
people from all over the globe for the
world's best quarter title
data constituency services or tcs
organizes code beta
winners usually win prizes like cash
prizes or
free vouchers
it also opens up a door for career
opportunities for its learners
next up geek coding challenge
key coding challenge is a three day
event
organized by geeks4geeks
in gcc learners can participate and
challenge themselves in solving coding
problems to win prices
next up code jam
code jam is a google hosted and managed
international programming competition
the competition consists of collection
of algorithing
that must be completed within a specific
time limit
at last courtship
quote chef is a website that aims to
assist programmers in succeeding in
algorithms computer programming and
programming competitions
code chef often organizes various
contexts like cook-offs and lunch time
we have now discussed various coding
platforms or competitions to hone your
skills
first up let's say if you can't solve a
problem in under an hour
you should put it aside for the time
being and move on you can always return
to it at a later time
next up
even if you answer the question
correctly i recommend that you read the
discussion and look at other solution
you could come up with a better way to
answer that question
finally if you are having trouble
understanding a solution then i
recommend you to dry run of the code
introduction to time complexity
the time complexity of an algorithm is
the amount of time it takes to run as a
function of the length of that input
the length of the input determines how
many operation the algorithm will do
it will provide the information about
the variance increase or decrease in
execution time as the number of
operations in an algorithm increases or
decreases
next up types of time complexity
we will start with the constant time
complexity
then we will discuss linear
logarithmic
quadratic
time complexity
now let's have a look at them
in the detail
first
constant time complexity
when an algorithm is not reliant on the
input size n it is set to have constant
time of order
big of 1.
the runtime will always be the same
regardless of the input
as you can see in the code every line
has the runtime of 1
and they are all independent of any
input size so the runtime is always
constant
next up linear time complexity
when an algorithm's running time
increases linearly with the length of
the input it is said to have linear time
complexity
when a function checks all the values in
an input data set it is said to have the
time complexity of order of big o of n
as you can see in the code the loop
depends on the size n
so the time complexity will rose up to n
next up logarithmic time
complexity when an algorithm lowers the
input data in each step then it is said
to have the logarithmic time complexity
binary trees or binary search functions
are some of the algorithms with
logarithmic time complexity
as you can see in this code by finding
out the mid in every iteration the
runtime will decrease every step
making it approximately logarithmic
runtime
next up quadratic time complexity
when the execution time of algorithm
rises non-linearly up to n square with
the length of the input it is said to
have quadratic time complexity
in general net nested loops falls into
the quadratic time complexity order
where one loop takes big o of n and if
the function contains the loop inside
the loop then it multiplies
as you can see in this code because of
the nested loops the time complexity
rose to n square
now that you have the firm grasp of time
complexity and its type we will discuss
essential steps to evaluate the time
complexity
to understand this we will take an
example of fibonacci number
this code prints the fibonacci numbers
till n
we will divide this code into three
parts isolating all the loops that play
a significant role in altering the time
complexity
let's look at the first part
it consists of some independent
statement which gave
constraint time for each statement
next let's move on to our next part that
is for loop
since this loop runs n times this will
give linear time complexity on n
next up the third part
which also has the constant time
complexity
now let's take a total of runtime
which comes out to be n plus 5
we will then discard the constant part
to find the time complexity which does
not affect the overall time complexity
now we will have the final time
complexity of bigger of n
we have now discussed time complexity
and how to evaluate it
now let's have a look at the time
complexity of various algorithm
we will look at the time complexity of
insertion sort merge sort quick sort
bubble sort
and some searching algorithms like
linear search and binary search
let's look at them in the detail
first up insertion sort
as you can see in this code we are using
nested loops
so in worst case its complexity comes
out to be n square
now in the best case scenario the
complexity will be linear time
complexity
next up
merge sort
in this case whether it is the worst
case or the best case it will always
remain and login
as every statement in this code will run
the same amount so no matter what its
time complexity will remain the same
next up quick sort
the time complexity of quicksort in the
best case is n login
n
and in the worst case it is
answer
next up bubble sort
as you can see in this code we are using
nested loops
so in the worst case its complexity
comes out to be n square
now in the best case scenario the time
complexity will become the linear time
complexity that is n
and after that we will discuss some of
the searching algorithms first up linear
search
in the best case scenario if the
statement to be searched is at the first
position then the time complexity will
come out to be constant
whereas in the worst case the time
complexity will come out to be n
finally binary search
in the best case scenario if the element
is to be searched is at the mid then the
time complexity will come out to be the
constant
whereas in the worst case scenario the
time complexity will come out to be big
of log n
we have now discussed the time
complexity and how to evaluate
and the time complexity of various
algorithm
now let's sum up what we have learned
from this session
first up the execution time increases
with the types of operations we make
using the inputs
next up the lesser the time complexity
the faster is the execution
finally if a code is of hundreds of
lines then it takes a toll on the pc's
processor
so it is essential to check and reduce
the time complexity as much as we can
let's get started with what are pointers
a pointer is a variable that points to
an address of another variable
it is declared using a star symbol also
called asterisk
and then we allocate a memory of a
variable to it
we can access a variable's address using
the ampersand symbol in the same manner
as the pointer declaration let's write a
code
we will declare a variable a equals 5
and a pointer ptr
then we will assign this variable a's
value to pointer ptr
now let's write a print statement to
directly access the variable's value
using variable name
let's write another print statement to
print the value of a using pointer
let's try and execute this program
as you can see we have successfully
accessed variables value using both
variable name and pointers
let's get back to our slides
now let's discuss different types of
pointers
first of null pointer
void pointer
while pointer
and dangling pointer
let's discuss these in details
first up null pointer
it is a kind of pointer that points to a
null memory
as you can see in the figure here is a
pointer which is pointing to a null
memory
to get a better understanding let's try
a simple program in the code editor
let's write a code
first we will declare a pointer where
then we will assign its value to null
now let's try to print the statement
let's execute this
as you can see since this pointer points
to another or nothing that's why it
doesn't print anything
let's get back to our slides next
void pointer when a pointer is created
with data type void then this pointer is
called void pointer
if we want to print the variable's value
then we have to typecast this pointer to
avoid any error for better understanding
let's get back to the code editor and
try it with a simple code first we will
declare an integer variable a is equals
to 5
and a void pointer ptr
now we will assign address of a to
pointer ptr
let's write a print statement to print
this pointer
let's run this program
as you can see we are getting an error
that's because we can't print a void
variable
in this we have to typecast this
variable to integer let's do this
we can typecast a variable like this
now let's print this
as you can see we can print it now
let's get back to our slides
next while pointer
when we create a pointer but don't
initialize it by assigning any memory to
it then this kind of pointer is called
while pointer
these pointers can be very tricky
they can even cause a program failure or
a segmentation fault
let's get back to the correlator and try
it with a simple code
first let's declare a pointer ptr
but they will not assign it with any
address
let's write a print statement to print
it this time we will directly print it
let's execute this
as you can see we are not getting any
results because there is no value
assigned to it sometimes it may even
show segmentation error
let's get back to our slides
next dangling pointer
let's suppose there is a pointer p which
is pointing at a variable
now if we deal locate this memory using
a free function
then this pointer will point at a free
space or a non-existing memory
then this pointer will become a dangling
pointer
to get a better understanding of this
pointer let's try it with a simple code
let's declare a pointer ptr
here we will dynamically allocate memory
using a mail off function
to do this we will put int star
in a bracket
then
well lock function
and in another bracket we will put
memory size to be allocated
now let's declare a variable a
and assign its address to the pointer
now to make it a dangling pointer we
have to diallocate the memory of this
pointer
we will use free function for that
now let's write a print statement to
print this pointer
let's execute it
as you can see since we have diallocated
its memory that's why it is pointing to
nothing hence it doesn't print anything
let's get back to our slides
till now we have discussed pointers ways
to access variables and types of
pointers
now let's talk about use cases of
we will talk about point to arithmetics
pointer to pointer array of pointers
call by value and call by reference
now let's dive right into it let's talk
about point to arithmetics we can use
four arithmetic operations on pointers
increment decrement
addition or subtraction of an integer
from a pointer
since pointer operates on addresses it
only makes sense if we apply pointer
arithmetics on sequential data
structures like arrays or strings
let's discuss them in detail first up
increment
if we apply this operator on a pointer
then it will shift this pointer's
address to its sequential successor
as you can see in the figure as we
increment the pointer's value we shift
to the next index of the array
let's get back to the code editor and
try it with a simple program
let's declare an array of size 3.
let's give them some value
we will then declare a pointer
and assign it to the arrays first
element
now let's write a for loop to traverse
this array
in this for loop we will increment a
pointer's value
and
print this pointer's value to traverse
this array
let's try and execute this program
as you can see we have traversed this
complete error
let's get back to our slides
next decrement
if this operator is applied on a pointer
it will shift this pointer's address to
its sequential predecessor
as you can see in the figure as we
decrement this pointer we also shift to
array's previous index
let's get back to the code editor and
try to implement it let's declare an
array of size 3
and assign it some values
now let's declare a pointer
and assign arrays last elements address
to it
now let's write a for loop
to traverse this array
in this for loop we will decrement the
pointer's value
also we will keep printing this
pointer's value to travel this array
let's try and execute this program
as you can see we have traversed this
complete array from the back
let's get back to our slides
next the addition of an integer to a
pointer
if this operator is applied on a pointer
it will leak forward accordingly
if the integer is 2 and our pointer
points at the first element then the
pointer will sequentially skip one
element and shift to the next element
let's implement it in the code editor
let's declare an array of size 7.
and assign them some value
then declare a pointer
and assign it to the array's first
element
now let's take an integer n to add in
the pointer
now let's write a for loop to traverse
this array
in this for loop we will increment the
pointer's value with integer n
and we will keep printing the pointer
ptr value
let's execute this code
as you can see we have traversed this
complete array skipping one element at a
time
since we have skipped three elements
that's why we are getting last three
values as garbage values
let's get back to our slides
next
subtraction of an integer from a pointer
if this operator is applied on a pointer
then accordingly it will leap backward
if the integer is 2 and our pointer
points at the last element
then the pointer will skip one element
and shift to the previous element
let's try and implement it in the code
editor
first let's declare an array of size 7.
and assign it some values
then declare a pointer ptr
and assign it to the array's last
element
now let's take an integer n to subtract
from the pointer
now let's write a for loop to traverse
this array
in this for loop we will decrement the
pointer's value with integer n
also we will write a print statement to
print this ptr's value
now let's try and execute this program
as you can see we have traversed this
complete array from back skipping one
element at a time
since we have skipped three elements
that's why we are getting last three
values as garbage values
let's get back to our slides
let's talk about precedence of these
operators
operator asterisk and ampersand have the
same priority as the unary operator
increment and decrement
these operators are evaluated from right
to left let's understand this concept
with an example
suppose if a pointer p points to a
variable x then we can swap x with
pointer p in that expression
in the first row we have y is equal to x
plus 1 which means we are storing an
incremented value of x in y similarly if
we replace x with a pointer p we can
store incremented value of pointer in y
in row 2 and row 3 we are incrementing x
and storing incremented value in x
itself
we can do this with pointers as well
in row 4 we are attempting to execute
pre-increment with a pointer p
in row 5 we are attempting to execute
post increment with pointer p
here we have to put star p in braces
because these operators are evaluated
from right to left so to give more
priority to pointer p we have to use
braces as they have highest priority
let's talk about another use case
pointer to pointer
basically in this situation a pointer
will point at a variable via another
pointer
we declare it with two statistic symbol
let's discuss it with an example
suppose a pointer 1 points to a variable
and another pointer 2 points to that
pointer 1.
this way pointer 2 will indirectly be
pointing to the variable
let's go to the code editor and try
implementing it
first we will declare a variable where
a pointer ptr1
and a pointer to this pointer ptr2
then we will assign this variable vars
address to ptr1
and
ptr1s address to ptr2
now we will write a print statement to
print variable var ptr1 and ptr2
now let's try and execute this program
as you can see
ptr1 and ptr2 shows variable vars value
as ptr2 is pointing to ptr1 and ptr1 is
pointing to that variable so indirectly
ptr2 points to the variable var
thus it prints the variable's value
let's get back to our slides
let's discuss the array of pointers
as the name suggests
it is an array that has all its elements
as pointers
these pointers can be pointing at
another array it is declared as an array
with asterisk symbol
let's discuss it with the program
first we will declare an array a of size
3.
then we will declare
a pointer array ptr of size 3.
now we will write a for loop to assign
a's elements address to ptr's element
then we will write another for loop to
traverse ptr and print its element
foreign
let's try and execute this program
as you can see it prints the value of
array a's elements because error ptr's
elements are pointing to arrays elements
let's get back to our slides
next call by value
we don't use pointers in this concept
but it is very important to understand
this concept to get better understanding
of the next topic call by reference
in call by value we call a function and
directly pass the variable's value as
parameters
in this situation a copy of those
variable is created and get passed into
a function as parameters
if we modify these parameters it will
not affect actual variables rather these
copies will get deleted as soon as the
function body ends
let's try implementing it in the code
editor
let's write a code
first we will declare a variable x
equals to 100
then we will write a function called to
function func with argument x
next we will write a print statement to
check if any changes happen due to the
function
now let's write definition for this
we will take a void function
with argument as x
in this first we will set x equals to
and then we will write a print statement
to print this value
let's try and execute this program
as you can see here when we get back to
the main block from function its value
again reverted back to 10
because in call by value program we only
pass variables copy into the function
not the actual variables
let's get back to our slides
next
call by reference
in this if we call a function but this
time we pass the variables address as
parameters
then in this situation actual variables
will get passed into the function as
parameters
if we modify these parameters it will
modify the actual variables even outside
the function scope
let's try implementing it in the code
editor
first we will declare a variable int x
equals to hundred
next we will write a function call for
function func
with argument as address of x
then we will write a print statement to
check if any changes happen due to the
function
now let's write definition for this
it will be a void function
with argument as pointer x
in this we will first set x equals to
then we will write a print statement to
print this value of x
now let's try and execute this program
as you can see this time variable access
value didn't revert to hundred
that's because in call by reference we
pass actual variables address two
functions so it will modify them as well
let's get back to our slides
during the course of this video we have
learnt a lot about pointers let's
discuss some advantages of the pointers
first up pointers are useful to access a
memory location pointers are also an
effective way to access the array
elements
pointers are used for the dynamic memory
allocation and its distribution
pointers are also used to build complex
data structures like linked list graph
tree stack queue etc
now let's talk about some disadvantages
as well
first up pointers are difficult to
understand so a programmer needs to be
careful while handling them
they might raise some errors like
segmentation error or access some
unrequired memory and course program
failure
if a pointer is pointing to an incorrect
value then it might corrupt memory
pointers may also cause memory leakage
also pointers are slower than variables
so to understand this let's go through a
simple concept
let us imagine that we have some data
and the data is related to students
right so if we wanted to store the marks
of individual students then we had to
declare a variable for each of the
student
so you can see we have student 1 student
2 student 3 4 and 5 and their individual
scores so the score 1 is assigned to
student 1 and so on with student 5 being
assigned to score 5.
so in the real time this might be a
little clumsy
we have here just five students so that
is okay but what if we had 500 students
or 5 000 students right that might be an
issue there we have to create some 500
or 5000 variables and it would be a
little tough to handle that right even
if we wanted to apply some operations
collectively on all the variables that
might be a little tedious
so what if we had one variable which
could store all the five students or 500
students or 5 000 students all together
and make it really easy for us to apply
some operations collectively on all the
students right this sounds a little bit
logical
so similarly we do have a data structure
which can do that which can collectively
store all the data elements in it as a
single variable and it will also help us
to apply the operations which are
logical or mathematical on all the
variables and their values together as a
whole so that is the purpose why we had
created arrays that is the purpose why
we needed arrays
so far we have understood what was the
necessity for arrays now we will
understand what exactly are arrays
so basically an array is a linear data
structure that stores the elements in a
sequential manner one after the other
and when you declare an array the
variables will be stored one besides the
other that is adjacent to each other in
a sequential order now let us understand
how the array is represented by the
compiler
now the next part that is the memory
representation of aries
now let us imagine that we have declared
an array which stores character type
data and another important point to
remember about r is when you declare an
array it stores only a single data type
typed elements only for example here we
have declared a character type array
right so we cannot store integer type
data or flow type data in it we only
have to save character type array or
character type elements in this
particular array
so now let us imagine that we have
created an array which is of character
data type and these are the elements
which are a r r a y now how does the
compiler represent it in the form of
memory
so when you create an array
these are formed that is the index
values and the address so basically
compiler will select a block of memory
and it has addresses to that block and
it can be anything right here we have 11
12 13 14 and 15. and in real time it
might be a thousand one thousand two
thousand three thousand four thousand
five the main motto is assign a
sequential block of memory and this is
the array and the elements are a r r a y
and this particular one which is the
last one is the index of the array that
is the position of the array for user so
using this index you can access the
elements in the array more on that in
the accessing part
so let us imagine that we wanted to
access the element r so how to access it
we might not know the address right in
that instance we will use the index this
is for our reference so we will tell i
want the element from array index number
2 and then will have the ar
r element so in the practical form this
is how we use the index
now let's continue with the lower bound
and the upper bound so the first initial
location is called as the lower bound
and at the last or the max value of the
array is called as the upper bound now
let us jump into the next topic where we
will understand the different types of
arrays
so these are the different types of
one dimensional arrays and
multi-dimensional arrays
in multi-dimensional arrays we have two
more types that is two-dimensional
arrays and three-dimensional arrays
so how are arrays different from each
other
right so the first one will deal with
the first one that is the one
dimensional array now how is an array
declared as one dimensional for that we
need subscript
so one dimensional array requires only
one subscript to specify the number of
elements in an array so how is it
actually represented so here you can see
an example right on my screen
so here is how a one-dimensional array
looks like so here we have the data type
that is integer data type and marks is
the name of the array and this is the
size of the array and here the elements
will be stored
and here it is the index value of the
array and remember the index value of
array always starts from zero in the
previous example that was only for basic
understanding so i just started that
with one in the practical way the array
index always starts from zero
so followed by the one-dimensional array
we will deal with the multi-dimensional
arrays in that we have the following
the first one is the two-dimensional
array and the second one is the
three-dimensional array
in the multi-dimensional arrays we
require more than one subscript in the
previous example we had one dimensional
array so the subscript is just one that
is 10 columns
right so we just had one single row and
10 different columns but in the
multi-dimensional arrays we need
multiple rows and multiple columns
right so we need two subscripts for two
dimensional array and more than two
subscripts for three dimensional arrays
so first we have the two dimensional
arrays
the 2d array is organized in the form of
a matrix which can be represented as a
collection of rows and columns so here
is the example as you can see on my
screen we have three columns and three
rows
and we have two subscripts that define
the number of rows and the number of
columns and the elements in each and
every row so the one two three confines
the first row four five six confines the
second row and seven eight nine will be
the third row
now similarly we have three dimensional
arrays a 3d array is a collection of 2d
arrays which consists of three
subscripts block size row size and
column size
so here we have an example for that
so we have three subscripts that is the
first one is block size the second one
is the row number and the third one is
column number
so this happens to be the first block
this happens to be the second block and
this is how a three dimensional array
can be represented
now we have the next stage where we will
understand how to declare the arrays and
the syntax is right on my screen you
need to specify the data type of the
array which is integer float or
character any selection which you make
followed by that you need to select an
array name for your array and inside
that you need to declare the array size
and sometimes you can also eliminate the
array size if you wanted to you know
have a dynamic array
and here is an example for that
you have integer data type name of the
array is example and the array size is
6.
so the compiler will allocate continuous
memory block of 6 integer type blocks
so
these are the few more methods to
initialize the array so here you can see
integer data type array name is a
element size is five and we have five
elements the method two is remember i
have said you can eliminate the size of
the array right so here you can use this
way as well integer data type array name
a and no size here and you can directly
declare the elements
and the method third so here you have
the name of the array size of the array
and you are allocating the elements to
the individual memory locations there is
also another method to initialize array
and method 4 is using a forum you can
just initialize a for loop and the i
value will be stored in the array
locations starting from 0.
now let us understand how to access the
elements in an array
so to access the elements in an array
you need to specify the name of the
array and memory block where you have
that element that you want to access so
here we have an example
which is integer data type name of the
array is xyz and the element we wanted
to access as 5 so here we have an
example that is integer type array array
name is xyz and it has the size 5.
and now we wanted to access the first
element in an array that can be done
using the first index that is xyz of
zero index that is the first element and
accessing the second element and so on
xyz of one will be the second element x
y z of 2 3 4 will be the third and
fourth and fifth elements
now let us understand some basic
operations that can be performed on the
array elements
so the following are the operations that
can be performed on the array elements
that is the traversal insertion deletion
searching and sorting
now let us get into practical mode and
try to execute some examples based on
traversal of the array insertion of an
element into the array deletion of an
element from an array searching for an
element in an array and sorting the
complete array so at first we'll carry
out the traversal operation so here we
have an array that is a of 5 and the
elements are 1 2 3 4 and 5. now we're
going to use a for loop to traverse
through this array and print all the
elements sequentially now let us execute
this code and see the output
so as you can see the code got
successfully executed and the elements
that is 1 2 3 4 and 5 from the array a
are printed sequentially
now moving ahead we'll try to execute
some examples based on insertion of
element into the array so on my screen
you can see an example for inserting an
element into the array at the starting
position of the array now let us try to
execute this code and see the output
don't worry about the codes these code
documents will be attached in the
description box below and you will be
able to have an access to it and run
these codes in your personal laptop and
get a better learning experience
now you can see the code got
successfully executed and now it is
asking for the size of the array let's
declare it as 5
and now let's enter the elements into
the array
now it is asking for the element to be
added at the beginning of the array now
we have 2 3 4 5 and 6 existing in the
array let's add the first element 1
and there you go the resultant array is
one two three four five and six the
element which we added at the ending
which is one is supposed to be in the
first or the beginning part of the array
which is here at at the first index
location as planned now let's get
started with another example on the
insertion
now let's try to insert an element at
any given location as per the user's
choice
so as you can see we have a program on
my screen and running this program must
help us to insert an element into any
given location of the array
now let's try to quickly run this
program and see the output
so there you go enter the elements into
the array
let's enter 1 3
let's try to run this program and see
the output
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and now the output
is asking for us to tell it the number
of elements in an array now let's say
four elements
so now let's enter the four elements
one
three
four five and six
okay so the four elements which is one
three four five are been inserted now it
is asking for the location where you
want to insert the element now let us
insert it in the second location
now let us set the value as two and
there you go the resultant array is 1 2
3 4 and 5 and the element which is 2 was
supposed to be added in the second
location and it has been successfully
added now let's try to execute another
example based on insertion where you
will try to insert the element in the
last position
now this program on my screen will help
us to add an element at the end of the
array let's quickly run this program
now it is asking for us to enter the
five elements of the array let's enter
that
now it is asking to enter the element to
be inserted now let us enter the element
and this element should be added at the
end location as discussed
the resultant array is one three five
seven nine and eleven
now let's continue with the deletion
operation
now the program on my screen is an
example for deleting an element from the
beginning position of an array now the
program got successfully executed and
it's asking for us to enter the size of
the array let's enter the size as five
and now let's enter the elements of the
array that is one
two three four
and five
now the element from the first location
that is one has been deleted and the
resultant array is two three four and
five now the code on my screen will help
you to eliminate the element from the
ending location of an array now let's
try to quickly run this program and say
the object
so you can see that the program is
successfully run and it is asking for us
to enter the size of the array let's
enter 4.
now let's enter the elements of the
array that is 1 2 3 and 4.
now after eliminating the last element
from the array that is 4 we have the
resultant array that is one two and
three
now a little homework for you guys let's
try to execute an example for deleting
an element from any location of an array
this will be a homework now don't worry
try on your own and if you don't get
that you can refer to the comment
sections below where you have the code
document attached in the description box
and you can refer to it
now let's continue with the next
operation where we will search for a
given element in the array
so you can see that on my screen we have
an example which will help us to sort
the elements in an array let's quickly
run this
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and now it's
asking for the array size let's enter 5
and now let's enter the elements in a
random order
[Music]
now the resultant array should be sorted
so there you go the array after being
sort is it's 2 3 5 14 and 21 so there
you go the array got sorted so now we
have finished our practical session
let's have a quick overview again
so traversal in an array is a process of
visiting each element once traversal can
be done by various means that is by
counting the array elements printing the
values sorted in the arrays and sum of
all elements present in the array and
many more
so this is how we traverse our array
from the first location to the last
location again the insertion operation
insertion in an array is a process of
including one or more elements in an
array and it can be done at the
beginning at the end and at any given
index of an array which we executed for
all the three types of examples
now next we have the deletion operation
so deletion operation or deletion of an
element is a process of removing a
desired element and reorganizing the
array and it can be done at the
beginning at the end and at any given
index so we have executed the example
for at the beginning and at the end and
the homework was at the given index
don't worry if you don't figure it out
you can always refer to the example
document which is mentioned in the
description box below
now the search operation searching is a
process of finding a given value in the
list of values and it decides whether
the search key is present in the array
or not and we have executed an example
on that
and again the sort operation where we
will sort the given array
if the given array is not in the default
order or in a given order that is
ascending or descending then we can sort
the order of the array by the user's
choice given it is ascending order or
descending order
now in the next section of the tutorial
we will discuss the advantages of using
arrays
so the first one is array stores
multiple elements of same data type with
same name
next one elements in an array can be
accessed randomly using just the index
number
array memory is predefined so there is
no extra memory loss
array avoids memory overflow and finally
2d arrays can represent the tabular form
of data in a very efficient way now let
us also have a look on some of the
disadvantages of using arrays
the first one the number of elements in
an array should be always predefined so
there is no chance that you can add some
extra element in the last moment
array is static in nature so its size
cannot be varied after declaration
what if consider that you wanted to
store 10 student data in one array and
you end up having just seven students so
the remaining three is a waste right so
you are wasting memory there that's the
problem and insertion and deletion
operations in an array is quite
difficult as the array stores elements
in a continuous form
and finally allocating excess memory
then required mainly to memory wastage
now we have the final key takeaways of
the arrays
so we discussed why do we need arrays
then we discussed what are arrays
followed by that we discussed types of
arrays next we had a declaration of
arrays accessing elements from an array
initializing the arrays and basic
operations on ira that is the practical
demo part and finally we have discussed
the advantages and disadvantages of
using an array
so we will see a brief definition of
arrays the array is a data structure
that stores elements of the same data
type in a sequential order
two-dimensional arrays are considered as
an array of arrays
two-dimensional arrays represent the
information in the form of rows and
columns which is completely similar to a
tabular form of data following by the
definition and briefing of the two
dimensional arrays
we will understand the need for two
so the main advantage of using a
two-dimensional array is the elements
can be represented in the form of a
matrix that is rows and columns
using two-dimensional arrays we can
initialize access and print multiple
elements in the matrix form by just
running one single quote segment
you can see an example right on my
screen here
this is an example of marks list suppose
a class has three subjects namely
english science and maths
we have four students and we wanted to
represent the data in the form of a
database so here the marks of the four
students can be represented using two
dimensional arrays
now we will see the syntax of a two
dimensional array so here the syntax
at first we need the data type the data
type can be integer character float
string etc then we have the name for the
two-dimensional array and later we can
have two subscripts which represent two
dimensions that is the rows and columns
the first subscript defines the number
of flows and the second subscript
defines the number of columns and note
that the column number can never be null
and the end we have a semicolon to
terminate the syntax
and here we have some examples of two
dimensional arrays so in the first
example we have the name of the two
dimensional array and we have
three rows and four columns
and followed by that we have another
example which is of character data type
and the name of the array is names and
we have 7 rows and 15 columns
next we will see how to visualize two
dimensional arrays
we read earlier that two-dimensional
arrays are a collection of rows and
columns let's see an example of
two-dimensional array
we will consider an array with six rows
and four columns
as you can see on my screen we have
integer type array and the name of the
array is array and we have six rows and
four columns
the product of rows and columns will
give us the total number of elements
present in a two dimensional array
in the current example we have six rows
and four columns and the product is 24
so we must have 24 elements in this
array
next we will see how to initialize two
dimensional arrays
so there are two ways to initialize a
two-dimensional array so in the first
method we declare the elements in the
set of curly brackets
this array consists of three rows and
three columns
note that the index always starts from
zero here we have three rows it means
the row starts with zero and ends with
two
the same goes for the column but
sometimes this method might be a little
confusing so we have a better method the
advantage of this method is clarity
we can visualize all the elements with
better clarity compared to the previous
method so the first three elements are
and 1
they are present in the first row
and in the second row we have
144 70 and 50. they comprise the second
row and finally the third row in which
the elements are 10 12 and 78
so far we have learnt how to visualize
and initialize a two dimensional array
so we have done it by using the index
values that is the row index and the
column index so the row index value was
three and the column index value was
three for accessing an element in the
two-dimensional array we need to pass
the name of the two-dimensional array
followed by the row index value and the
column index value for example let us
assume that we wanted to access the
element 9 for doing so we will pass the
name of the array followed by the row
index value and the column index value
as shown below that is int first zero
comma zero
and an important point here is indexing
always starts with zero
we will now start printing the two
dimensional arrays
so to print a two-dimensional array we
will be using two nested for loops
so to understand the process of printing
the two-dimensional array let's get back
to the practical mode and we will work
on a code
so on my screen you can see an example
for two dimensional adding so here we
have declared an array with the name
first and we have three rows and three
columns and inside that the first row of
elements is 961 and the second row of
elements is
70 and 50 and the third row of elements
is 10 12 and 78
followed by that we have two counter
variables which are i and j
so we are using the first counter
variable i in the order for loop and the
second counter variable j in the second
in the form
and inside the inner follow we have a
print statement which is used to print
the elements in the array
now
let us try to execute this code and see
the output
so you can see the code got successfully
compiled and we have our elements here
which is 961 144 70 50 10 12 and 78 now
let us understand the logic so here we
have declared the counter variable as 0
and the condition is i should be less
than 3 which is true so the control will
enter into the second inner for loop
here we have j is equals to 0 and j
should be less than 3 which is true so
here the condition or the statement
is valid and it will print the first
element 9.
followed by that j will be incremented
again j is now equals to 1 and j is less
than 3 so again we'll print the second
element 6.
again j value will be incremented to 2
so 2 is less than 3 then we will print
the third element that is
1.
now when you increment the value of j
from 2 to 3 the condition will fail
because 3 cannot be less than 3
so the control will enter into the outer
for loop here we have i value is equals
to 0 which will be incremented to 1.
so 1 is less than 3 again the control
will enter the inner follow here again
we will check for j is equals to 0 which
is true so we will print the second row
of elements that is 144 70 50 in the
same way how we printed the first row
right so j will be equals to 0 so then
we'll print the first element so j will
be incremented to
1 and 1 is less than 3 then we will
print the second element that is 17 and
again j will be incremented to 2
and 2 is less than 3 so we will print
the third element that is 50 in the
second row
and again j will be incremented to 3 now
the compilation of the condition will
result in false so it will exit the
second follow-up and but it will come
back to the first outer for loop now the
value of i will be incremented to 2 so 2
is less than 3 the control will enter
into the inner for loop again then we
will print the third row of elements
that is 10 12 and 78 in the same way how
we printed the first row and the second
row
after printing the third row the
condition will fail when j value is
incremented to 3 and it will enter the
order for loop here the i value will be
incremented again from two to three and
the condition fails now the overall
control will come out of both the for
loops and it will terminate here
so that's how we got nine six one forty
four seventy fifty ten twelve and 78 so
with that we have come to the conclusion
and so far we have learned the following
things
what are two dimensional arrays why we
need two dimensional arrays syntax of 2d
arrays visualizing 2d arrays
initializing 2d arrays accessing 2d
elements and finally print the elements
of two dimensional arrays let's get
started with what is linked list
a linked list is a linear data structure
made up of nodes these nodes consist of
two parts data and reference to another
pointer
typically a linked list starts with a
head node which goes all the way up to
the last node which is called tail
next let's discuss why do we need linked
list
a linked list is a linear data structure
like arrays
but an array can only offer a fixed size
whereas a linked list can dynamically
increase its size
also operations like insertion and
deletion are much easier in a linked
list than in an array
now let's try to implement the linked
list in the code editor
let's start by creating a node
to create a node we need a class
let's declare a class node
we will declare its member as public
the first member is end data
and the second member is node
pointer
next
now we will go into the main block and
initialize our first node
to initialize a node we need to use node
star
the node name had
equals to
n
similarly we will
create more nodes
and our last node
now we will allocate these four nodes in
the heap
to do that we will use
a node name
equals to
new node
star
braces
now we will allocate all the nodes in
the same manner
now we will assign data to our first
node
to access the member of the node class
we will use error formation
then we will use data
equals to
let's give it a value as 2.
now we will link this first node with
that second node
to do that we will use
head
same error formation
and next
which will be equals to
r
n1 node
and now we have
created our first complete node
now let's create other nodes as well
and one arrow data
is equals to
let's give it three
and one arrow
next
is equals to
n2
and two arrow
data
is equals to
five
and to arrow
next
to arrow
is equals to
tail
now
tail is equal still arrow data
equals to 7.
and
tail
arrow
next
is given
null
now let's call up function to print this
list
we will give head as the argument
as
we can only traverse a linked list from
its head
let's write a definition for this print
list function
this function will be a void function
argument is
not star
a
we will use while loop to traverse this
linked list
we will give it it condition
if a is not equals to
null
is
a data
and l
now we will change
our cursor
from the current node to the next node
to do that we will use
a is equals to a arrow next
now let's try to execute this code
as you can see we have traversed our
complete linked list
now let's get back to our slides now
let's discuss different types of linked
list
the first are singly linked list
next is the doubly linked list
the circular linked list and finally we
have the circular doubly linked list
let's discuss each one of these in
details
first up single linked list
it is a unidirectional linked list
while using the sinclair linked list we
can only traverse it in one direction
that is from head node to the tail node
next up doubly linked list
it is a bi-directional linked list we
can traverse it in both the directions
in this linked list the node has an
additional pointer that points to the
previous node
next up circular linked list
it is a regular linked list except for
its last node points to the head node
programmer needs to be careful while
traversing it or they might get stuck in
an infinite loop
next up the circular doubly linked list
it is a combination of doubly linked
list and a circular linked list
its last node points at the head node
and the previous pointer of the head
node points to the last node it is also
bi-directional linked list so that we
can traverse it in both directions
we have now discussed the linked list
why do we need linked lists and types of
linked lists now let's learn about some
operation we can apply on linked list
we can use majorly two operations on
linked list
first up insertion and deletion
we can perform these operations in three
different situations
first at the beginning
at the last or at a specific position
after a node
next we will discuss these operations in
detail
first of insertion
we will discuss first in session at the
beginning
we have to give the first notes address
to the new nodes next pointer to execute
this
next up insertion at the end we have to
give the new node's address to the last
node's reference pointer
next up insertion at a specific position
to do this we will have to change the
reference address of the previous node
to the new node's address
and the new nodes reference pointer to
the next node's address
now let's discuss deletion
first up deletion at the beginning
we have to change the first node's
address to the null to execute this
next up deletion at the end
we have to change the second last node's
address to the null
next up deletion at a specific position
we will change the reference address of
the previous node to the next node's
address
we have learned a lot about linked list
during this session
now let's discuss some benefits of
linked list
first up a linked list is a dynamic data
structure
that is we can dynamically increase its
size
next it offers easy insertion and
deletion
than other linear data structures like
arrays and string
since it can dynamically increase its
size resulting in no memory base stage
next
it is pretty handy in implementing
complex data structures like stacks and
queues etc
now let's talk about some disadvantages
as well
first up since the linked list is made
up of nodes it takes extra storage for
storing data and reference pointer
next the traversal in the linked list is
a bit harder than other data structure
reverse traversing is easy in doubly and
circular doubly linked list but since it
uses one extra pointer it takes extra
storage making it another limitation
let's get started with introduction to
single linked list
a single linked list is a linear data
structure made up of nodes
these nodes consist of two parts
data
and reference to the another pointer
these nodes can be traversed using
pointers
it starts from the head node all the way
up to
tail node
now let's try to implement the singly
linked list in the code editor start by
creating a node
to create a node we need a class
let's declare a class node
we will declare its member as public
the first member is end data
and the second member is node
pointer
next
now we will go into the main block and
initialize our first node
to initialize a node we need to use node
star
the node name had
equals to
similarly we will
create more nodes
and at last repeat and our last node
tail
now we will allocate these four nodes in
the heap
to do that we will use
a node name
equals to
new node
star
braces
now we will allocate all the nodes in
the same manner
now we will assign data to our first
node
to access the member of the node class
we will use error formation
then we will use data
equals to
let's give it a value as 2.
now we will link this first node with
our second node
to do that we will use
add
same error formation
and next
which will be equals to
our
n1 node
and now we have
created our first complete node
now let's create other nodes as well
n1 arrow
data
is equals to
let's give it three
and one arrow
next
is equals to n2
and two arrow
data
is equals to
and 2 arrow
next
to arrow
is equals to
tail
now
tail is equals tail arrow data
equals to 7
and
tail
arrow
next
is given
null
now let's call up function to print this
list
we will give head as the argument
as
we can only traverse a linked list from
its head
let's write a definition for this print
list function
this function will be a void function
argument is
not star
a
we will use while loop to traverse this
linked list
we will give its fit condition
if a is not equals to
null
then
t out
is
a data
and l
now
we will change
now we will change
our cursor from the current node to the
next node to do that we will use a is
equals to a arrow next
now let's try to execute this code
as you can see we have traversed our
complete linked list
now let's get back to our slides
we have now introduced the singly linked
list
now let's discuss some of the operations
we can apply on a linked list
first up insertion
we can perform insertion at three
different situations
like at the beginning at the last or at
a specific position after a node
next up deletion
similar to the insertion we can perform
it in three different situation as well
at the beginning at the last or at a
specific position after a node
let's talk about them in detail first up
insertion at the beginning
to execute this we have to give first
node's address to the new node's next
pointer
next up insertion at the end
to execute this we have to give new
nodes address to the last node's next
address
next up insertion at a specific position
to execute this we will change the
previous node's reference address to the
new node's address and the new nodes
reference pointer to the next node
address now let's try these operations
in a code editor as you know a linked
list is made up of node so we should
start by creating a node to create a
node we need a class
node
and we will define its members as public
print
data
and
node pointer
next
now we will create a function to insert
a new node in front of the list
for this function as an argument we will
give the reference to the head of the
list
and integer dot new data
now in the definition we will allocate a
node
newnode equals to
now we will put in the data in the new
node
we will use arrows to put to access the
data
equals to
new
now we will make the next of this new
node as head
now we will move the head to point to
the new node
now we will create another function to
insert a node after a specific position
as arguments we will give it
the address to the previous node
and
the integer new data
we will first check if the given
previous node is null
it is we will print
given note
and not
and then we will return the function
otherwise
otherwise we will allocate a new node
and then we will enter the new data
now we will make the next of the new
node as a next of the previous node
and then we will move the next of the
previous nodes
as new node
now we will write a function to insert a
node at the end of the list
as an argument we will give it
a node pointer to pointer
and
and integer new data
we will first allocate a new node
we will also create a last node
and give it
now we will put in the data in the new
node
since this new node is going to be the
last node so we will make its next as
null
now if the linked list is empty then
we'll make the new node as head
to check that we will use
if
star head
is equals to equals to null
if it is then we will do
star head
equals to new node
else
we will traverse it to the last node
file
last
next
partner
last
is equals to
asked
next
now we will change the next of the last
node
as new node
now we will write a function to print
this list
while
is not null
out
code
arrow
data
and then
and node
equals to
node
now we will write the code for the main
block
first we will define a head node
and mark it as null
now we will start using those functions
to make a linked list
first we will use append function
to add
6 in it
next let's let's use another function
push
and add 7 in it
now we will try to insert one at the
beginning
so we will use push again
comma one
now let's try to insert four at the end
so far the list looks like one seven six
four null
now let's
let's try to insert eight after seven
to do that we will use insert
after
as argument we will use head next as 7
is present next to the head
comma
now let's try to print this linked list
see out
created
yes
list
add
return
let's execute this
as you can see we have created the
linked list in the correct order
let's get back to our slides now let's
talk about deletion first up deletion at
the beginning
to execute this we have to change first
node's next address to null
next up deletion at the end
to execute this we have to change the
second last node's address to the null
next up deletion at the specific
position
we will change the previous node's
reference address to the next node's
address
now let's try these operations in a code
editor
we will start by creating a class
in this class we will declare the
members as public
print
data
and
the node pointer next
now to insert the data in the node we
will use
a function
push
as argument we will give pointer to
pointer node
header
and
integer new data
we will allocate a new node
we will give this new node the data as
new data
and
and new nodes next as head
now we will write a function to delete
the node
as argument we will give a node pointer
to pointer
head
and end key
now we will store head in a temp node
and we will create a node prev
as null
if head node itself holds the key to be
deleted we will use f
amp is not equals to
null
and
temp
data
is equal to equals to key
then head
equals to
next
now we will free the old node
else we will search for the key to be
deleted
while
amp
is not equals to
and
temp data
is not key
so rev
equals to temp
and temp
will be hydrated to its next
if
the key is not present in the linked
list
then we will just return the function
else we will unlink the node from the
linked list
and delete
now we will write a print list function
to print the list
its argument will be a node pointer node
while
a node is not null
layout
less than
node
data
and we will iterate this node
using node equals to
node
next
now we will move on to the main block
we will start with the empty list
node
star
head
equals to null
now we will add the element to this list
so push
ampersand
head
comma seven
next push
push
ampersand
next push
add
comma
nine
now see out
created
test
and listed
now we will use delete node function
delete
two
we will use argument as
ampersand head
comma
two
now
we will check
the linked list
of
two
test
let's try and execute this
as we can see we have deleted the two
from the linked list let's get started
with an introduction to double a link
list
a w link list is a linear data structure
made up of nodes
this linked list is a bi-directional
link list that is we can traverse it in
both direction
these nodes consist of three parts first
up data reference to the next node
and reference to the previous node
now let's try to implement the wlink
list in the code editor
as you know a linked list is made up of
nodes so we will start by creating a
node to create a node we need a class
node
its members should be defined as public
inc data
pointer
next
and node pointer
now we will write a function to insert a
node at the beginning of the doubly
linked list
void
push
argument will be a node pointer to
pointer
add
and
end new data
now let's allocate a node
node star
new node
pulse
new
node
now let's put in the data into the new
since we are adding at the beginning its
previous is always null
now we will link the old list of the new
node
now we will change the previous of the
head node to the new node
we will check if head is not null
then heads previous
is equals to
new node
now let's move the head to the point to
the new node
now let's write a function to print the
given way like
its argument will be a node
we will iterate it until the node is not
null
layout
node data
and
node
equals to
node next
now let's write a code for the main
block
we will start with the empty list
now we will use a push function to push
values in the function
another push function
add
comma
three
push function
ampersand
head
comma five
push function
add
comma 7.
now
layout
probably
list
and we will call the print list
function in the double linked list
let's execute this program
as you can see we have successfully
created our first doubly linked list
let's get back to our slides
we have now introduced doubly linked
list
now let's discuss some of the operations
we can perform on a doubly linked list
we can perform three operations on a
doubly linked list
first traversal
insertion
and deletion
we can perform a traversal in two ways a
normal traversal and reverse traversal
and we can perform insertion and
deletion in three different situations
at the beginning at the last and at a
specific position after a node
let's discuss these in detail first up
normal traversal
we can traverse a doubly linked list
using a next pointer starting from head
to all the way up to tail node
reverse traversal similar to the normal
traversal we will use previous pointer
we will start from the tail node to go
all the way up to head node
now let's try to traverse the doubly
linked list in the code editor
let's start by creating a class node
we will define its members as public
print data
node pointer
next
and node pointer
prep
now we will write a function to insert a
node at the beginning of the doubly
linked list
by push
its argument will be a note pointer to
pointer head
and integer new data
now we will allocate a node
our
new node
new
node parenthesis
now we will put in the data
since we are adding at the beginning so
its pref is always null
now we will link the old node to the new
node
now we will change the previous of the
head node to the new node
now we will move the head to the point
to the new node
now we will write a function to traverse
the linked list normally
void
traverse
node pointer
while loop
node
is not null
therefore
p out
data
node
equals to node next
now we will write a function to reverse
traverse it
its argument will be a node pointer to
pointer
add
we will create a note tail
equals to head
while
else next
is not null
this loop is enabling us to reach to the
tail node so that we can traverse it
from back side
now
while loop
until tail
is not equals to
head
out
and
first row
here
data
this last c out statement is only
because we are not traversing till the
head pointer
now let's go to the main block
let's start with an empty list
note star
add
equals to
null
now let us create a linked list to test
the function so we will use push
function
add
comma two
another push function
ampersand head
comma three
push
add
comma
since we are inserting at the beginning
so the actual linked list looks like
five
three
now
we will print the original linked list
first
see how
original
traverse
and
reverse traversal
first traversed
linked list
now let's try and execute this program
as you can see we have traversed it in
the
normal way as well as the reversed way
let's get back to our slides
next up insertion at the beginning
we will create a node with the previous
pointer pointing to a null and the next
pointer pointing to the head node
then we will change the head node's
previous pointer to the new node and we
will change the new node to the head
node
next up insertion at the end
we have to give the new node's address
to the last node's next pointer and
change the new node's previous pointer
to the last node
next up insertion at a specific position
we will change the previous node's next
pointer to the new node and the new
node's previous pointer to the previous
node and the next pointer to the next
node
and vice versa
now let's try these operations in a code
editor
we will start by creating a class
node
public
node pointer
rev
note pointer
now we will write a function push
set a note at the beginning of the list
its argument is note pointer to pointer
add
new data
we will first allocate a new node
node star
new node
plus new
node parenthesis
now we will put in the data
node
arrow
data
is equals to new data
now we will make the next of the new
node as head
and previous as null
and new node
previous
is equals to null
now we will change the previous of the
head node to the new node
first we will check if the head node is
null
then
star head
previous
equals to
new node
now i will move the head to the point to
the new node
now let's write another function to
insert a node after a specific position
void
insert after
argument will be
node pointer
rev
rev node
and
data
if we first check if the given previous
node is null
yes then we will give it c out
given node
b
none
and we will return to the function
or else we will allocate a new node
let's do new
now we will put in the data
now we will make the next of the new
node as the next of the previous node
equals to
ref
node
now i will make the next of the prep
node as new node
and make the prev node as the previous
of the new node
now i will change the previous of the
new node's next node
f
new node
next
not null
then
new node
text
is equals to new node
now let's write another function
insert a node at the end of the list
void
append
argument will be
a node pointer to pointer
head
new data
first we will allocate a new node
equals to
new
parenthesis
now we will create another node last
equals to head
now
we will put in the data
the node
data
equals to new data
now since this new node will be the last
node so its next will be null
add
equals to equation null
node
first equation null
and
star head
equals to new node
return
or else we will traverse till the last
node
i
next
is not null
last
equals to
last next
now we will make the last node as the
previous of the new node
return
now we will write a print list function
to print this list
argument is
a node pointer node
while
code
is not null
out
data
or is equals to node
next
now
let's write the main block
we will start with an empty list
we will start by inserting 6 so the link
list becomes 6 null
and
ampersand
head
almost 6
now we will insert seven at the
beginning
push
percent head
comma seven
now we will insert one at the beginning
also
now we will insert four at the end
till now the link list looks like
now we will insert eight after seven
so insert
after
add
next
comma
eight
now
let's print
this linked list
let's try and execute this
as you can see we have created our
linked list in the correct order
let's get back to our slide
next up deletion
first up deletion at the beginning
we have to change the first nodes next
to null and second nodes previous to
null
next up deletion at the end
we have to change the second last node
next pointer to null and delete the
previous node to free up the space
next up deletion at a specific position
we will change the previous node's next
pointer to the next node
and next node's previous pointer to the
previous node
now let's try these operations in a code
editor
we will start by creating a class node
click
and data
node pointer
next
put pointer
f
now we will write a function to delete a
node in a doubly linked list
void
delete
node
its argument has pointer to the head
repeat its argument as pointer to the
head node pointer
and pointer the node to be deleted
now we will check the base case
condition
that is if
add
is
or
note to be deleted is null
and return
now
if
the node to be deleted is a head node
and
is equals to
now
if
next node of the dell
partner
that is
if
the node to be deleted is not the last
node
then
else next
abs
equals to
that's
now we will change prev only if not to
be related is not the first node
so if
del
rev
not equals to
null
then
del
rev
next
equals to
del's next
finally
we will free the memory occupied by the
dell
free
and
now let's write a function to insert a
node at the beginning of the way linked
list
right
counter to the head node pointer
and enter new data
we will allocate the node
now we will put in the data
since we are adding at the beginning so
prep is always null
now we will link the old list of the new
node
now we will change the prev of the head
node to the new node
you
now we will move the head to the point
to the new node
now let's write print list function
note pointer node
file
mode
is not equals to null
t out
node data
code
first to
node
next
now let's get started with the main
block
we will start with the empty list
now we will create new nodes
push
ampersand
add
comma 4
push
ampersand
add
comma 6
push
percent head
comma 8
now let's print this list
layout
original list
in a list
now we will call the print list function
head
now we will delete the node from the
doubly linked list
here we are deleting the first node
next let's delete the last node
now the modified list
should look like
or eight
let's try and print this
see out
divided
last
let's try and execute this
as you can see we have deleted all the
nodes except for 6 and 4.
let's get started with introduction to
circular linked list
a circular linked list is a linear data
structure made up of nodes
it is like a single linked list except
its last node points at the head node
these nodes consist of two parts data
and reference to next pointer these
nodes can be traversed using the next
pointer
now let's try to implement it in the
code editor we will start by creating
nodes
to create a node we need a class
node
we will define its members as public
linked data
and node pointer
next
now let's write a function to insert a
node at the beginning
void push
we will use arguments as a pointer to
node pointer head
and enter data
we will define a node
new node
equals to new
node parenthesis
our head
now we will put in the data into a new
node
since we are inserting at the beginning
of the linked list that's why this new
nodes next should be the head pointer
if linked list is not null then set the
next of the last node as head
file
next
is not equals to
head
the temp
is equals to
lamp
arrow next
now
then
next
is equals to new node
else
new node
next
is equals to
new node
star head
equals to newnode
now let's write a function to print this
linked list
void
print list
node
star head
star temp
is equals to head
if
add
is not equals to
null
then
do
data
next
while
amp
is not equals to
head
this condition is important to stop this
loop so that it doesn't go infinitely
now let's go to the main block
let's initialize this list as empty
node
star head
equals to null
now let's insert some nodes in this
linked list
push
ampersand head
comma
to
push
ampersand
ampersand head
comma 11.
five
now this linked list looks like
then it will again go back to 5
now let's try to print this
c out
circular
list
now let's try and execute this
as you can see we have successfully
created our first circular linked list
let's get back to our slide we have now
introduced the circular linked list now
let's discuss some of the operations we
can apply on a circular linked list
we can perform two operations on a
circular linked list
first up insertion
we can perform insertion at three
different situation at the beginning at
the last and at a specific position
after a node
next up deletion we can perform deletion
at the three different situations
first up at the beginning at the last
and at a specific position after a node
let's discuss these in detail first up
insertion at the beginning
we have to give the first node's address
to the new nodes next pointer to execute
this
next up insertion at the end
we have to give new nodes address to the
last node's reference pointer
next up insertion at a specific position
we will change the previous node's
reference address to the new node's
address and the new node's reference
pointer to the next node's address
now let's try these operations in a code
editor
so far we have implemented a linked list
using classes
now let's try to implement it using
structures
we will start by creating a struct node
with its element as int data
and struct
node
next
now we will write a function which can
only insert a node to empty list
struct
node
star
add
empty
star
last
comma
new data
now since this function is only for the
empty list so we will have to check if
the link list is empty or not
if
last
is not equals to
null
then we will return
last
now let's create a node dynamically
struct
node
start temp
equals to
struct
load
star
malloc
size
we will copy this statement because we
will need it in the future functions
we will assign a data to this new node
temp
data
is equals to
neutral
data
last
is equals to temp
now we will create the link
to that we will use last
next
is equals to last
since we are in an empty list so the
first node will always point to itself
return
we are creating a function to insert at
the beginning of the linked list
struct
node
star
add
again
as argument we will use struct
node
if last
is equals to null
then we will return
add empty
last
map data
now we will create a node
dynamically
i have already copied this statement for
the ease
now we will put in the data
data
is equals to data
and
next
is equals to
last
next
is equals to
return
last
now we will write a function to insert a
node at the end
last
hit
if
last
equals to equals to null
and
return
add empty
last
comma
data
now we will dynamically create a node
and put in the data
data
equals to data
next
is equals to
last
next
now last next
equals to
temp
and last equals to
return
now we will write a function to insert a
node after a specific node
so struct
node
star
add
after
start
into data
and
item
this item is a node after which we have
to insert the node
if
last
equals to equational
then
return
node
temp
comma
star p
p
is equals to
last
next
now do
if f
goes to
item
equals to
we will dynamically create a node here
temp
is equals to
struct
load
star
lock
size of
struct
load
now we will put in the data
so temp
data
is equals to data
temp
next
is equals to
a p next
temp
if e is equals to last
last
is equals to
temp
return
last
next
while
last
text
item
not
present
in the list
return
last
now we will write a function to print
this list
void
front
list
struct
node
star lost
star p
now if
last is equals to null
then
see out
list
is empty
and return
else
we will point to the first node of the
list so p
is equals to
last
text
to traverse the list we will use do
while loop
so
do c out
data
is equals to
me next
while
e
is not equals to
last
text
now let's write a code for the main
block
we will start with an empty list
struct
node
star
last
supposed to
none
now last
is equals to
add
empty
last
comma
six
last equals to add begin
last
comma
last equals to
add
begin
last
comma two
last equals to
add
and
last
comma
equals to
add
after
last
comma
list
let's execute this
as you can see we have created the
linked list in the correct order
let's get back to our slides
now let's talk about deletion
first up deletion at the beginning
we have to change the first node's
address to the null to execute this
next up deletion at the end
we have to change the second last node's
address to null to execute this
next up
deletion at a specific position
we will change the previous node's
reference address to the next node's
address
now let's try these operations in the
code editor
let's get started with creating a node
to create a node we need a class
node
we will declare its members as public
and data
node pointer
next now we will write a function to
insert a node at the beginning of the
list
void
push
a pointer to the node pointer header
and new data
now let's create a node and make head as
next of it
load
star
node
equals to
new
node parenthesis
let's put in the data
new
node
data
is equals to new data
and
new node
next
is equals to
had
if linked list is not null then set the
next of the last node
as the first node
if
star head
is not null
then we will find the node before head
and update next to it
so node star
temp
is equals to star head
while
next
is not equals to header
temp is equals to
tamp
next
now temp
equals to
new node
else
next
is equals to
new node
and star head
is equals to
new node
now let's write a function to delete a
given node from the list
so
void
delete
node
its argument is a pointer to the node
pointer
add
and
end key
now if linked list is empty then we will
simply return it
if
star head
is equal to
null
then return
otherwise
if
and
add
next
is equals to head
then
free
add
is equals to null
return
now
node
last
is equals to
star head
comma star d
now if head is to be deleted
then
star head
data
is
equal to
key
then
while
last
next
not equals to
star head
then last
is equals to last next
now we will point the last node to the
second node of the list
now we will free this head
our head
equals to
last
next
now if either the node to be deleted is
not found or the end of the list is not
reached then
while
last
next
is not equals to
head
and
last
next
data
is not equal to key
and
last equals to
last
if not to be deleted was found
then
if
last
next
data
is equals to key
then
d is equals to
last
next
and
last
next
is equals to
d is next
now we will free
d
or else
see
out
no such
key
formed
foreign
now let's write a function to print this
list
void
print list
node star
head
node
star
temp
is equal to
head
if
is not null
then do
c out
temp
data
amp
is equals to
temp
next
while
temp
is not equals to head
c out
now let's write a code for the main
block
we will start by empty list
so note star
head
equals to
null
now we will push
ampersand head
push
comma
ampersand head
seven
push
ampersand head
comma
and push
ampersand head
comma 10
now we will print the list before any
deletion operation
c out
list
before
deletion
list
head
now let's delete
out
rest
after deletion
print list
let's execute this
as you can see our deletion function is
working perfectly
in this particular session we will
discuss the differences between the two
major data structures that are the
arrays and linked lists
so at first what exactly is an array so
an array is a linear data structure that
stores homogeneous data elements in a
continuous form
so homogeneous in the sense you will be
able to store only one single data type
of elements in an array for example
consider that you have declared an array
and you wanted to store some elements in
the array so you can declare a data type
first after that the name of the array
and if you declared that the array
should store integer data type then you
can only store integer elements in that
particular data type you cannot store
any other data type like float or
character that is the meaning of this
particular definition and it stores the
elements in a continuous order that is
in the adjacent format as you can see in
the example here 10 20 30 40 and which
are located in the adjacent locations
that is 0 1 2 and 3. now let us
understand what exactly is a linked list
so similar to array even a linked list
is a linear data structure but the only
difference is it is a dynamic data
structure here you can increase or
decrease the size of the linked list in
runtime
the only difference is here the memory
locations are not adjacent to each other
but they are taken from the memory heap
so there is a huge memory chunk out of
that the linked list will borrow some of
the memory locations and one after the
other the memory nodes will be
interconnected using pointers
so that was the difference between array
and linked list and similar to arrays
even the linked list store homogeneous
type of elements that is if you declare
a linked list of float data type then
you can only store flow data type in it
you cannot store any other different
data type like character or string
now followed by that let us understand
the types of arrays
so basically we have three different
types of arrays those are the
one-dimensional arrays and inside
multi-dimensional arrays we find two
more types those are the two dimensional
arrays and three dimensional arrays
now one dimensional arrays will be
having only one subscript that is where
they'll be having only one single row
whereas in the two dimensional arrays we
will be having two subscripts that is it
will be having rows and columns and in
the three dimensional arrays it will be
having three subscripts that is the row
column and the block address now
followed by the types of arrays we will
understand the types of linked lists
so similar to arrays even linked lists
are divided into three types they are
singly linked list doubly linked list
and circular linked list the difference
between them is a singly linked list
will have two parts that is the node
address and node element in this
particular segment the element will be
stored and in this particular second
segment the address that points to the
next node will be saved and similarly in
the circular linked list the only
difference between the singly linked
list and the circular linked list is at
the end of the single linked list we can
see a null pointer which indicates the
end of the linked list but in circular
linked list the address will not be null
instead it will point back to the head
node that is what which makes it as a
circular typed singly linked list or a
circular linked list when it comes to
the third type that is the doubly linked
list
we can see there are two address
locations the first starting node will
have null as its first address location
then will store the element and the
second address location will point to
the next node and you can see in the
second node will have element and the
first address location will point to the
previous node and the second address
location will point to the next node and
at the end the second address location
will be pointed as null which indicates
as the
end of the linked list
now that we know the types of linked
list and arrays we will look into the
fundamental differences between arrays
and linked lists
so the first fundamental differences
between the arrays and linked list is
the array element can be accessed
randomly using just the index values but
whereas random access is not possible in
linked list if you want to access any
element in linked list you need to
perform the traverse operation
sequentially
the second difference between the both
is
array is static which means memory size
is fixed which cannot be changed in
runtime but whereas in the linked list
the memory is dynamic which means you
can either shrink or expand the memory
in runtime according to your
requirements
followed by that the next difference is
each element in array is independent in
nature that is you can access any
element just by giving the index
location whereas in linked list the
elements are interdependent on each
other whenever you want to access a
specific element you need to go through
the other elements or traverse through
the other elements
next one is the array takes more time in
operations like insertion and deletion
whereas linked list takes less time to
perform the operations of insertion and
deletion followed by that the next
difference is accessing any element is
faster in array as random access as
possible and the array data structure
just by using its index values but
whereas accessing an element in linked
list is slow because we know that we
need to traverse through all the node
elements to access a particular element
now the next difference is in case of an
array memory allocation is done in
compile time whereas in linked list the
memory allocation is done during the
runtime
memory utilization is inefficient in an
array as it is allocated as in static
and it is allocated during the compile
time in case of linked list the memory
utilization is very efficient as the
memory is allocated during the run time
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
what is a stack
so basically stack is a linear data
structure just like arrays and linked
lists the only difference is that it
follows a specific order when an
operation is implemented on it so what
is the specific order that it follows
that is lifo last in first out or failo
first and last out in the next part we
will understand this order in a much
better way
all operations can be done only at the
one end of the stack that is on the top
now we will discuss much about that in
the operations part of the stack now let
us understand the first fundamental that
is the representation of stack that is
how do you represent a stack normally
so a stack can be represented using two
different methods that is using an array
or using a linked list so in an array we
will be using the continuous memory
and in stack we will be using a
non-continuous memory and the stack will
behave like a dynamic stack or a dynamic
data structure
now the first method that is the array
method
so in this method an array is used to
represent the stack as you can see in
the image below we have a stack
so the name of the stack is stack itself
and you can see two more things here
that is top is equals to 2 and max is 4.
so the max is the value of the array or
the length of the array the maximum
length of the array and top is the
position where the last element of the
stack is present here in this case 56 is
the last element in the stack and top is
inclined or it is addressing to that
particular address that is two
and now let us discuss about the linked
list representation of stack
so in this method a dynamic data
structure that is a linked list is used
to represent the stack this
representation leads to a dynamic stack
it does not need to define the maximum
number of elements present in the stack
remember in arrays we had to define the
max value in the previous example we had
the max value as 5 but in here you need
not to assign the max value as the stack
itself as dynamic
the pointers links are used to store the
address of the upcoming nodes and the
variable used in this method is top so
the top is holding the address of the
topmost element in the linked list
representing the stack
now moving ahead we shall understand the
basic operations on stack now here we
will understand the previously discussed
definition that is push pull etc in a
much better way so the basic operations
on a stack are push pop or pull and peek
now let us discuss each one of them in a
detailed way the first one is push
operation
so the push operation is the mechanism
of inserting a new element into the
stack
as you can see we are trying to insert
the elements from the top so the push
operation basically involves the
following steps check if the stack is
either full or not
so basically whenever you are trying to
insert an element into the stack you
need to make sure that the stack is
empty or it has some space if it is full
you cannot insert an element into the
stack step two if the stack is full
produce an error and exit that's what i
was talking about now the step three
if the stack is not full increment the
top by one that is when you're inserting
an element then you need to update the
top value for example in the previous
slide when we had the array
representation of a stack we had the top
value as 2. so if you try to include an
element into the stack then you need to
update the top value from 2 to 3 that is
incremented by 1.
now the fourth step add data elements to
the stack where the top is pointing
and finally success the push operation
has been successful so this is how you
insert or push an element into the stack
now followed by push operation we have
pop or pull
so the pop operation is a mechanism of
eliminating or deleting or removing one
data element from the existing stack
so we shall understand the
pop operation in a much more detailed
way the operation involves checking the
stack is empty or not if in case the
stack is not empty then you can carry
forward the pop operation but in case if
the stack is empty then you have to
provide an exit status and exit the
control and leave the stack
so if the stack is not empty approach
the data element at the top that is at
the top position for example in the
previous array example remember right we
had the top position pointing towards
two so you need to take the control to
the top position and pick out the
element and pop it
and finally decrease the top by one so
when you eliminate the top element then
the top value from 2 will be decremented
to 1. so this is how the pop operation
is carried over on a stack
next one is
the peak operation the peak operation
involves returning the topmost data
element from the stack without moving it
so here you can see the top is pointing
to the element number four
and you're picking the
element number four and you're not
removing it from the stack you're just
returning the topmost data element
you're passing the value of the top
element
so to understand the push pop and peak
operations on stack in a much more
better way let's carry out a practical
example
now we are on the practical mode and
here you can see on my screen we have
the code example for the stack
now first we'll be checking if the stack
is empty as per the steps mentioned in
the previous discussion we will check if
the stack is empty or not if it is empty
then we will return else we will
continue and again another step we also
check if the stack is full if the stack
is full we will exit else we will
continue with the operation whatever it
is peak pop or push and here we have an
example for the peak operation that we
discussed previously and followed by
that we have a pop operation we are
trying to exclude an element from the
stack
and another one we have the push
operation where we'll be trying to push
the elements into the stack so these are
the three functions for push pop and
peak now we'll try to push in the
elements and also pop and
try to involve some functions on it or
run some operations on the stack now
let's run this code and see the output
so you can see that the code has
successfully executed and we have the
statements here the first one says the
stack is not full that is false and
stack is empty that is true right and
after that you can see that the elements
which we try to push into the stack that
is 11 76 71 15 and 66 are been pushed
into the stack and if you clearly
observe it we have the element 11 in the
bottom 76 upon that 71 upon that and 15
and last 66. so the order is first in
last out that is the first element was
pushed first and when you are trying to
eliminate the elements from the stack
then you will first pick out 66 followed
by that you will pick out 15 followed by
that you will pick out 71 and so on so
this is the rule what stack follows
now i hope i made myself clear with the
example now we shall continue with the
applications of stack
so these are the few applications of
stack the first one is expression
conversion
so you can see we have the infix
notation prefix notation and postfix
notation so the infix notation is no
rocket science there is only one thing
here to learn that is we have two
operands a and b and we have one
operator that is the addition operator
in between those two operands
and when you use the prefix notation you
will have the operator located at the
first place then you will have the
operands followed by it
and in the postfix one you will have the
operands first and followed by the
operands you will have the operator
so basically all the infects prefix and
postfix notations give out the same
results but the only difference is
the representation of those operands and
operators
now let us understand this in a much
more detailed way
so conversion of expression from one
form to another form is
the main application of stack so we have
the first one that is infix to prefix
and infix to postfix now let us see an
example here you have one plus two star
three plus four so this is the normal
infix notation and when you
try to present the same expression in
the form of prefix notation so this will
be the result and this is the result for
postfix
the next one prefix to postfix and
prefix to infix
and this is the way you write the prefix
notation and if you want to convert that
to infix this is how you can write it
and this happens to be the result of
postfix notation
and finally postfix to prefix postfix to
infix and these are the results
now followed by expression evaluation
the next important
application of
stack is checking parentheses
and you can see if the parenthesis is
set properly the expression gets
evaluated if not it will not be
evaluated
now the last one memory management and
function call the very useful thing of
using a stack is
the memory will not be allocated to your
stack elements unless the function is
called here you can see it is the main
function and these are the elements that
you wanted to declare into your stack
and unless you make a function call the
elements will not be declared their
memory or the elements will not get the
memory allocated for them
now another good application of stack is
the backtracking problem or the end
queen problem
the end queen problem is an example of
backtracking problem the end queen's
solution to this problem is to position
the queen in such a way that the
opponent queen cannot attack your queen
now another example is string reversal
you can see on my screen we have a
string that is a b c d and e now using
stacks you can reverse this
right so you're basically eliminating an
element and relocating it to the first
place
and finally after reversing your string
this will be your result a b c d
and e
followed by that we have conversion
evaluation
so stack is used to evaluating the
expression as shown in the example
since parenthesis has the highest
precedence 5 4 gets evaluated first and
it will result in 9.
then multiplication and division have
the same precedence
now the associativity comes into picture
so the associativity is always from left
to right so first
4 into 9 will be executed which will
result in 36 and then 32 divided by 4
which will give us 8.
now we have 36 minus 8 which will give
us an answer that is 26.
now the last application is the tower of
hanoi so the tower of hanoi is a
mathematical puzzle consisting of three
rods and n discs
this puzzle consists of some rules
the first rule states that one disk can
move only at a time the second rule is
that the disk can only be moved when it
is at the uppermost position on the
stack
the third one no dusk is allowed to
place on the top of the smaller disk
so this is how the tower of hanoi works
what is the stack
so stack is a linear data structure that
follows fifo or first in first out
principle all the operations on the
stack are done only from one end that is
the top
so you can see this image here and this
particular image of books can be
considered as stack and you can see that
the addition or elimination of elements
that are spokes in this particular case
is happening only through the top
section
now we will understand what are the
basic operations that can be performed
on a stack so the basic operations that
can be performed on a stack are
push pop and peak
so this particular image on the right
side will help you understand what
exactly is push pop and peak as we
discussed the elements will be added
into the stack from the top so when you
add an element from the outside into the
stack it will be pushed from the top
that is the push operation and if you
want to eliminate an element from the
stack it will be eliminated from the top
that is the pop operation
apart from these two that is push and
pop we have another operation that is
called as peak the main intention of p
is just to see the element which is on
the topmost part of the stack it will
just retrieve the element from the top
it will not pop it or it will not push
any other element onto the top it will
just copy and it will just print what is
present on the top so these are the main
operations that is push pop and peak
now let us see how to implement this
stack using array
so implementation of stack data
structure can be done in two ways that
is array and linked list
now in this particular session we will
learn how to implement stack using array
data structure
now without further ado let's get
started with the implementation of
stack so we will be performing push
operation that is inserting a new
element into the stack
now followed by that we will be
performing the pop operation onto the
stack
that is eliminating or deleting an
element from the top position of the
stack
and followed by that the last operation
that is the peak operation where we will
be just retrieving the topmost element
from the stack without removing that
element from the stack or without adding
any new element to the stack
now that we have a detailed
understanding of what are the basic
operations that can be applied onto the
stack let's get started with the
practical implementation
now you can see that on my screen we
have the basic fundamental operations
onto stack that has the push and pop now
without further ado let's get started
with running this code don't worry about
the code this particular code will be
present in the description box below or
if you need it you can always write down
to us in the comment section below and
we will have it sent to your mail id so
that you can have a better understanding
of the code and try to execute the code
in your local system
now let's run the code and see the
output
as you can see the code got successfully
executed and the topmost element is a
and the topmost element is b after the
element is being popped away and it says
that the element b was popped out and
after that the topmost element was a and
after that the element a was also popped
out and now the top is pointing to -1
which means to say that the stack is
empty
in this session we will learn about
linked list implementation using stack
so first up what exactly is a linked
list so linked list is a dynamic data
structure it allocates memory
dynamically the nodes are maintained in
a non-continuous memory that is in
linked list we have nodes so each and
every node is connected via a pointer
which points to the address of the next
node
each node contains next pointer that is
the next pointer's address which keeps
the reference to the next node and it
also has another section which stores
the data the topmost node always
contains null in its address
and this is how a linked list looks like
so this is the top which is the
beginning position of the linked list
and this is the address of the first
location and this is the next node this
is the following node then this is the
last node and this points back to the
head node so this is how you can
implement a stack like data structure
using linked list you can see that we
can perform stack like operation that is
the elements are located one above the
other and the top is pointing to the
head node
now let us go through the implementation
of stack using linked list first we will
go through traversing of stack using
linked list
so displaying each node of the linked
list representing stack is termed as
traversing copy the head pointer to the
temporary pointer and then move
temporary node through all the nodes and
display values of each node
so you can see the animation here will
explain you how the traversal goes
through the linked list in real time
now another linked list implementation
of stack is the push operation
so adding a new node to the top of the
stack is termed as push operation
generally in stack we have three
operations that is push pop and peak so
one of the operation is push where you
add an element into the stack in the
same way using linked list you can add a
new node to the stack and point it as
the top of the stack or the first
element which represents the top in
terms of stack
now create a node first and allocate a
new memory to it if the list is empty
and node consists of data and null is
the address it will be inserted as the
first node
if there is some node already existing
then add a new node at the beginning to
avoid violations
so the following animation will help you
understand how we add a new element or
the top element to the stack using
linked lists
now followed by the push operation we
have the pop operation
so now let us go through the pop
operation
removing a node from the top of the
stack is termed as pop operation
in the same way we will be eliminating
the first node from the linked list
which is termed as top
underflow condition may occur when you
try to remove the node if the stack is
already empty
in stack node can be removed from one
end only therefore the value stored in
the head pointer must be deleted and the
note must be freed
followed by the pop operation we have
the peak operation
retrieving the topmost node of the
linked list representing stack without
removing the linked list node from the
top of the stack is termed as peak
operation generally when you're using a
stack data structure just retrieving the
value of the top node is called as peak
operation you're not going to eliminate
or you're not going to add a new element
to the top you're just going to copy the
element or you're just going to retrieve
the element which is pointed as top this
operation is called as peak
now in the linked list you can also
perform this operation of peak
now with the theory discussed let us
execute a practical program based on
stack implementation using linked list
now on my screen you can see a code
example using which we will implement
stack using a linked list now here we
have the pop operation push operation
and top and then the main function don't
worry about the code this particular
code snippet will be attached in the
description box below or you can also
request us and we will have it sent to
your mail id and you can understand the
code and try executing in your local
system now without further ado let's
directly run the code
there you go the code got successfully
compiled and we have tried to add some
elements into the stack that is a b c
and c is being the topmost element of
the stack and that element has got
popped and followed by that the element
on the top currently after c being
popped out as v and the node element b
got popped again and the only element
which is present in the stack is a and
that element is also popped out after
performing the pop operation and now
currently the stack is empty you can see
that we have tried to push the elements
a b c and also we try to pop the
elements a b c
let's get started with introduction to
queue you know that all of us depend on
messaging applications like whatsapp
facebook messenger instagram chats to
communicate with our friends and family
members and while using them you must
have observed that the person you are
trying to communicate with receives
messages in the same order as you have
sent them now the question that arises
here is how is this happening how are
these applications maintaining the order
of these text messages
and the solution to these questions
bring us to queue
basically in these applications a queue
is maintained for each user containing
the messages to be delivered to the user
when the user connects to the network
all the text messages in the queue gets
delivered and once the messages are
delivered empty queues get deleted
this example clearly illustrates the
importance of data structures so let's
dive further and understand the
structure of the queue in depth
but before doing that let's look at a
real-life example of cues to understand
it more clearly
the most common and relevant example of
a queue is a movie ticket counter
in the movie ticket counter you must
have observed that both of its ends
remain open also these ends are fixed
with the help of barricades and that is
why no one can enter in between these
ticket lines
additionally the person who enters first
receives a ticket first and the person
who enters last will obviously get
served at last
queues and data structure resembles all
these properties of a movie ticket
counter which makes them better at
creating virtual first come first serve
systems
basically they are defined as a linear
collection of different data types that
allow insertion at one end and deletion
at another
unlike any other data structure the
queue ends remain open allowing it to
have different functionalities at both
ends
the end at which insertion takes place
is called rare
and the end at which deletion takes
place is known as front
furthermore there are two approaches to
consider the structure of the queue and
both of them depend on the approach of
the programmer
that means being a programmer if you
consider the left hand as front then
your rear node will be at right end
otherwise if you consider the left hand
as rare then the right end will be your
q's front node
unlike arrays and linked lists elements
in the queue cannot be operated from
their respective locations here they can
only be operated from the front or rare
position
moving on let's discuss the operations
in queue data structures one by one
the first operation is enqueue it is
used to store the elements in the queue
next up is dq this operation is used for
removing them
further we have isful and is null
operations is full function scrutinizes
if the queue is full or not and the is
null operation evaluates if the queue is
empty
we also have a peak operation that helps
you get the element from the front of
the queue without removing it
let's now understand how these
operations work with the help of the
following examples
here we will look at nq5 and q1 and q
minus 2 then is full
then dq
peak
and is null
but before explaining these operations
it's essential that we initialize the
queue data structure by assigning some
random size to it
for example int q of 3 by this
declaration we are assigning only three
spaces for insertion and q
also at this phase there is no element
in the queue as it's empty so both the
front node and rear node will point to
the same location with null memory space
in the storage system
let's consider that null index to be -1
for ease of r convention
now the first operation on our list is
enqueue of 5.
as we discussed previously enqueue
operation is nothing but the insertion
of data into a queue data structure
it begins with checking if the queue is
full or not
if the queue is full then the previously
assigned memory is completely filled
with data elements
so insertion would not be possible this
is also known as overflow error in terms
of programming
but as our queue is empty so the
insertion can be performed here for that
we have to increment the rare pointer to
index 0 from index -1
and once we do that the data element 5
will be added to the queue
also for front insertion both front and
rear will point to the same location as
there is only one element present in
this queue
let's insert two more elements into this
queue with the operations nq1 and q-2
for that we have to increment the rare
pointer to the next index which will be
1.
now as the point is incremented so the
data will be entered into this position
next up is nq minus 2. again we have to
follow the same process of incrementing
the rare pointer we will increment the
rare pointer to point towards the next
index that is index 2 and hence the data
element with value -2 will be entered
here
the next operation on our list is is
full in this operation if the rear
pointer points to the max size then the
queue is considered to be full as there
is no space left for insertion
in our case the max size of rq is 12
bytes
additionally we are considering to enter
only three integer elements
and one integer data element takes four
bytes of the memory space that means
three integer elements will take 12
bytes hence this function will prompt q
is full on the screen
now we will discuss the dq operation if
we want to access data from a queue we
have to perform two sub tasks the first
one is access the data where the front
is pointing and another is to remove the
data after access and this complete
process is called as dq operation
the first step of this operation is to
check if the queue is empty
if the queue is empty then there is no
element available for deletion this is a
case of underflow error
but as our queue is not empty we can
proceed with the next steps we will be
accessing data from the front node and
later we will be incrementing the front
pointer in order to remove the link to
the previous node so that the data gets
removed now front will point to the
index 1.
thus the data value 5 will be removed
from the queue and will also be prompted
on the screen
therefore this function comes with an
integer return type
next up is peak operation
in this operation element at the front
node will be accessed without deleting
it
the algorithm for this operation begins
with checking if the queue is empty or
not
if the queue is not empty then data at
the front node will be accessed with
temporary variable and printed on the
screen
advancing further let's perform two more
dequeue operations here first is dq of
one and another one is dq of -2
the data at a front node will be
accessed primarily and the front pointer
will be incremented to point to the next
data element
when we do the point incrementation the
link to the previous node gets remote
which results in data deletion
similarly we will perform a dq of minus
2 operation here now the front will be
pointed to null memory space as there is
no element left in rq and the data -2
will be removed
the last operation on our list is is
empty
this function checks if the queue is
empty or not in the previous procedure
we mentioned that if the front points to
the null memory space then the queue is
empty and in our case the front is
already pointing to -1
so the output of this function will be q
is empty
this is all about operations in the
queue i hope that you all are clear with
these operations
next we will discuss different types of
queues and their structures at a glance
basically there are four types of queues
linear queue
circular queue priority queue and double
ended queue
the structure which we have discussed
till this time is that of a linear queue
so now we will move on to circular queue
the circular queue is almost similar to
the linear queue except that the last
node of this queue is connected to the
first
it is also known as ring buffer as all
the ends are connected to another end
additionally this circular queue is a
better version of the linear queue as it
removes the drawback of insertion in the
linear queue
the empty space available in a circular
queue can be filled with the new element
by simply incrementing the value of the
rare position
we will learn about this in detail in no
further sessions
a priority queue is another special type
of queue data structure in which each
element has some priority assigned with
it
based on the priority of each element
the elements are arranged in a priority
queue if the elements occur with the
same priority then they are served
according to the first in first out
principle
in the priority queue the insertion
occurs based on the arrival while the
deletion occurs based on the priority
the above figure shows that the highest
priority element comes first and the
elements of the same priority are
arranged based on the first in first out
structure
the last type of queue is dq
dq is a linear data structure in which
the insertion and deletion operations
are performed from both the ends we can
say that dq is a generalized version of
the queue
dq can be used as stack as well as q as
it allows the insertion and deletion
operations on both the ends
if the insertion takes place at one end
and deletion at another then that dq is
known as a linear queue
and if both addition and deletion are
performed at a single end then that dq
is called stack
advancing further let's discuss some
applications of queues to gauge an
insight into the importance of queues
the queue data structure is used in
computers printers and applications to
utilize the benefits of the first come
first serve technique
in computers whenever you work on
documents or ppts you must have observed
that whichever key you press on the
keyboard appears in the exact same order
on the screen
but when your processor is too busy with
other tasks you might notice that the
keys you press appear on the screen with
some delay after you press them
basically those keys are stored in queue
and when the processor becomes free it
processes in the order the keys are
pressed
that means the key pressed first will be
written in a word document first
so this is how computers use a queue to
eliminate deadlocks when multiple
processes are in a ready state
next up is printers
a queue data structure is used in
printers to maintain the order of pages
while printing that means the pages are
stored in a queue in the order that you
want to print them and once the page is
removed from an ordered queue it gets
printed
another most common application of queue
data structure is their usage in web or
mobile apps
applications like domino swiggy uses a
queue for maintaining food order status
if you place an order from an online
portal your order id enters the queue
and once the previous orders before your
order id gets catered then your order
will be catered as well
from these examples we can clearly say
that queues are used whenever there is a
need for an fcfs strategy in software
development so whenever you work on
projects that need a first come first
serve approach then remember that you
have to implement a queue data structure
to complete it successfully
finally let's have a look at some key
takeaways that we discussed in this
session
we started this session by examining the
structure of the queue
we learned that the queue is a linear
data structure
after that we talked about different
operations of queues in which we learned
nq and dq are responsible for data
manipulation in a queue
later we discussed different types of
queues as well
finally we discovered some applications
of queues and how they fulfill the need
of fcfs systems
we have also made it clear that queues
can handle multiple data types as well
having said that let's dive deep into
the strategy to implement queue data
structure until now we have understood
that queue is a special kind of list
with some restrictions on insertion and
deletion and there are two approaches to
deal with queue implementation the first
one is array based and another one is
linked list based in this session we are
going to focus on array based
implementation
initially let's say we want to create a
queue of integer elements for that
purpose firstly it is essential to
declare an array of random spaces let's
take 100 as the size of our array that
means our array can have a maximum of
hundred integer elements the declaration
of an array is made with this line of
code intq hundred
where int represents integer data type
and q is the name of our array and
hundred is its size
the array that we just initialized is
going to store rq
by that what i mean is that any random
index of an arri q is going to start
with two marked ends front and rear
in this array i am showing front of the
queue towards the left and rear towards
the right
for making those end nodes we need to
initialize two pointers front and rear
at this moment as our queue is empty so
both of those pointers should point
towards -1 so initialization of these
pointers should be done as inch front is
equal to minus 1 and int red is equal to
-1
when the insertion or deletion happens
in queues these pointers will be either
incremented or decremented so they are
an essential part of this queue
implementation process
now you must be clear with the array and
pointers declaration part so let's dive
further and formulate code for queue
implementation using a one dimensional
array in c plus plus
it is essential to include header files
into our source file as we cannot access
standard c plus functionalities without
them
that is why here we are going to load io
stream and standard input output files
along with using namespace sdd
once this is done we will initialize our
array along with front and rear pointers
remember we always have to declare the
size of an array before compilation
that means we cannot update the size of
an array at runtime
this scenario is the biggest limitation
of queue implementation using arrays
having said that let's proceed with
pointers declaration
now we are done with the initialization
process
we will now work on implementation of q
functionalities
let's first work out supportive queue
functions like is null s full and peak
isn't function validates if the queue is
empty
and as per our previous discussion when
both front and rear points to -1 then
the queue is considered to be empty so
the condition to determine if q is empty
will be
if
rare is equal to is equal to -1
and front is equal to is equal to -1 it
will return q is empty
if the queue does not satisfy the
previous condition then it is not empty
so by using the else condition we can
display the queue is not empty
next up is is full function this
function validates if the queue is full
and we can clearly say that if the rare
pointer is equal to the max size of the
queue then our queue is going to be
completely full
next is peak
the peak function extracts the element
where the front pointer is pointing
without removing it from the queue
for this functionality to work our queue
must contain data elements in it
what i mean is our queue should not be
empty if our queue is not empty then
data at the front node can be accessed
this is how we implement supportive
queue functions let's immediately dive
into the development of main queue
operations nq and dq
for enqueue operation if the queue is
full then our function should prompt an
overflow error
for that to happen we have to put this
condition
if the front pointer is pointing to
minus one then we have to increment the
front pointer to zero manually
otherwise it can be incremented by rare
plus plus
after pointer incrementation we have to
ask for a data element to enter into the
queue
once the data is given it should be
inserted at the position where the rear
is pointing now
finally let's code the final main queue
operation called as dq
if the queue is empty then there is no
element for deletion so it should prompt
an underflow error on screen
also if there is only one element left
inside q then both pointers should again
be pointed towards -1
for that let's write another condition
here
if both the previously mentioned
conditions are false then deletion of an
element can be achieved by just pointer
incrementation
we have implemented all the queue
functionalities here but we haven't
implemented a function that can show us
how our queue looks so for that let's
implement one more function with the
name display
this function should prompt the elements
of the queue on the
screen elements will only be printed if
the queue is not empty hence we have to
check for the emptiness of the cube
first
finally we are done with the hard part
so let's arrive at the main function to
contemplate these operations in order to
visualize outputs
we are going to use a switch case to
take a user command
thus not to waste your time on this let
me just get done with this block asap
that's all we are done with the queue
implementation using arrays let's just
examine if our code works fine or not by
compiling it
this program should return a console
that asks the user to give commands for
performing different operations
so as you can see on your screens if i
input 1 i can perform insertion in a
queue
let's perform some insertions now we
will insert four elements
first three
then 21
next 78
and finally 12.
after inserting these elements we will
print the state of the queue using case
3.
now let's also check the dequeue
function
if we perform a dq operation then 3
should be remote from the queue
let's check if it is remote using the
display function
and yes our code works just fine
now if you're concerned about this code
then don't be as we can send it over to
you if you drop your email ids in the
comments section below
additionally you can also try to run it
on your local system to have a better
understanding of the concept
when we discuss the implementation of
queue using arrays we discussed the
limitation of fixed size according to
that limitation an array will always
have a fixed size and it should be
declared before the compilation of
program furthermore once all the
positions in an array are taken or it is
exhausted then we only have two options
we can either deny insertion by saying
that the queue is full and we cannot
insert anything now or what we can do is
we can create a new larger array and
copy elements from the previous array to
the new large array the time complexity
for this copy operation will be
proportional to the number of elements
inside field error in other words we can
say that the time complexity of this
copy operation will be big o of n
but again as we are giving random larger
size to the array there is a possibility
of massive memory loss
like right now in this area 70 percent
of the memory is unused and the memory
is a crucial resource that we should
always be protecting it's not that some
amount of unused memory will be real
problem in today's modern day computer
but it's just that while designing
solutions and algorithms we should
always analyze and understand these
implications regarding memory
along with this memory wastage there
exists another sort of memory management
issue that occurs while utilizing an
array to implement a queue data
structure the space of an array which is
used to store elements can never be
reused to store the queue elements
because items can only be inserted from
the front end and the front end's value
may be so high at that time the space
before the pointer will be lost for
eternity let's have a look at an example
to understand this drawback more clearly
in this example of array representation
of q a queue of size 10 having 5
elements is shown the value of the front
pointer is 5 therefore we cannot
reinsert values in the place of already
deleted elements before the position of
front that means the space of the array
before print pointer can never be reused
for storage purpose
these drawbacks represents the need for
a more appropriate method to implement
queues and by using a proper dynamic
data structure like linkedlist these
drawbacks can be easily removed on that
note let's discuss about the
representation of queue using a linked
list
a linked list as we know is a collection
of data elements that we call nodes
these nodes are stored at non-contiguous
locations in memory further each node
contains two fill one to store data and
another to store the address of next
field or the reference to the next node
let's assume that the node in this
figure are at addresses 200 400 and 500
respectively i have failed these
addresses in the address field as well
the identity of the linked list that we
always give with us is address of the
head node we often name a pointer or
reference variable at which we store the
address as head
so now we are saying that we want to use
a linked list to implement queue data
structure and the basic definition of
queue conveys that a queue is a linear
data structure in which insertion is
performed at the rear node and deletion
at the front node it's really effortless
to enforce this property of a queue in
linked list we can simply pick one side
of a linked list for insertion and
another site for deletion if the head
node is considered to be print then the
tail node will be the rear otherwise if
the head node is deemed to be the rear
then the tail node will be the front end
whatever side we are picking for
whatever operation we just need to make
sure one thing and that thing is the
operations that we are carrying out must
take a constant time or in other words
that time complexity should be big o of
one
i hope that you guys are clear with the
representation of a linked list as a
queue data structure now moving forward
we will discuss about its implementation
but before that let's have a look at the
time complexity management challenge
which occurs in queue implementation of
a linked list
in the case of linkedlist the cost for
insertion or removal from the head side
is big of 1 but the cause for insertion
or removal from the tail side is big of
n
so here is the d in a standard
implementation of q using linked list if
we insert element at one side and remove
them from other side then one of these
operation nq or dq depending on how we
are picking this side will cost us big o
of n
but the requirement that we have
specified before for q implementation
suggest that both these operations must
take a constant time
so we'll definitely need to do something
to ensure that both nq and dq operations
take constant time
let's call this side front and this side
rear
so i want to enqueue a node from the
tail side and i want to perform a dq at
the head side
we are good for dq operation because
removal from the front will take a
constant time but insertion or enqueue
operation will be costing us big of n
let's first see why insertion at the
tail will be costlier and then maybe we
can try to do something to insert an
element at the rear end what we will
have to do is first we'll have to create
a node let's say i have got this node at
address 350 and the integer that i want
to enqueue is 7 the address part of this
node can be set as null
now we have to build a link with this
created new node and to do that first
we'll set the address part of the last
node as the address part of this newly
created node but the only identity that
we always keep with us in case of linked
list is address part of head node so to
get appointed to any other node we need
to start at head that is why first we'll
create a pointer variable temp and will
initially set it to head node and now
using this temp pointer will traverse to
the end of our linked list that is the
tail node
and here using this pointer temp we can
write the address part of the newly
created node at the previous tail node
to build this new link
this traversal of pointer from head to
tail is taking all the time for
insertion we use a statement like temp
is equal to temp dot next to move the
next node what we can do is we can avoid
this whole traversal with the help of
pointer variable just like head node
we can call this variable tail or even
rear let's call this variable rear for
now and also the variable with storing
an address of head as front in any
insertion or removal we'll have to
update both print and rear now but from
now on whenever we will perform enqueue
operation we can directly check where a
rear node is and update its address to
formulate a new insertion link this
simple addition of one pointer resolves
a problem with the cost of insertion
let's understand this scenario with the
help of an example previously we were
traversing from head node to the tail
node but now as we know the location of
tail node there is no need for any
traversal we can directly update the
address part of rear node to make a link
for new node
here the new node with data element 7
will be linked to the previous node and
the rear pointer will also be updated to
point towards the newly inserted node
now the complexity for both the
operation will be big of 1
which means we can now begin with the
coding implementation of q using a
linked list
so let's dive directly into that
in order to get started with our coding
implementation we'll need to load some
dependencies that are called as header
files i have already included those
header files here so first of all we'll
declare a structure to create nodes for
our linked list and inside the structure
will initialize data and address part so
let's get started with creation of this
structure
struct
node
now the initialization of data and
address part
and
data
struct
node
star next
now using this created structure we will
initialize front and rear pointers so
let's create this front and rear point
struct
node
star
front
is equal to null
similarly struct
node star
rear
is equal to
none
the declaration of variables that we
have done here is in global scope the
reason behind that is to make sure that
these variables will be accessible to
all the functions
so moving forward let's work out the
primary queue operation we'll start with
enqueue operation so let's create a
function for that void
enqueue
and inside this function will pass an
argument in x to insert an element
now
inside the enqueue function will take an
integer as an argument in this function
will create a new node for purpose of
insertion so let's create that new node
struct
node
star
temp
is equal to
struct
node
star
malloc
size of
struck
no
so with this size of function we have
allotted the size of address part as
well as the data part
one more thing i want to tell you guys
is i am using malloc in c here for
dynamic memory allocation if you want to
implement this code using c plus then
you can use new operator instead of
malloc the purpose of using malloc here
is to create a node in dynamic memory
now moving ahead
we can start working on two cases of
enqueue operation primarily there won't
be any element inside the queue so for
the first insertion we'll manually set
both front and rear to the address of
this newly created node so to do that
first we'll have to create a if
condition
if
front
is equal to equal to null
and and
rear
is equal to equal to null
front
is equal to rhea
is equal to
temp
which is nothing but the new created
pointer variable and will return
the control
if this condition fails that means there
are already some elements present inside
our queue so
using else condition we can write
another statements
ria
dot next
is equal to 10
and rear
is equal to
10.
basically these two lines of code are
just updating the address part of the
next node along with setting the
temporary data into rear nodes data
field this code will be further clear if
i'll show things moving in simulation so
let's revisit powerpoint for that
purpose
let's say initially we have an empty
queue so both front and rear will be
null null is only a macro for address 0
at this stage let's say we are making a
call to enqueue function passing number
2 as an argument
now let's go through the enqueue
function and see what will happen
first we'll create a node the data part
of this node will be set as 2 and the
address part will initially set as null
let's say we got this node at address
so a variable name temp will store this
address right now the front and rear
both are null so we'll go inside this if
condition and simply set both front and
rear as hundred
after the first enqueue operation our
queue will look like this
let's say we are making another call to
enqueue function at this stage passing
number 4 as an argument once again a new
node will be created let's say i got
this new node at address 200 this time
the queue is not empty so in this
function we'll first go to the statement
rear dot next is equal to 10
so we'll set the next part of this node
at address 100 as the address of a newly
created node which is 200 so we'll build
this link now and now we'll store the
address of this new rear node in this
variable name rear so this is how my
queue will look like after the second
enqueue operation
i hope that you guys are clear with the
implementation of enqueue operation and
the working of its code
let's deal with the next queue operation
named as dq in our code editor
now inside this dq function i'll create
a temporary pointer to the node in which
i'll store the address of the current
front or head node so that we can
directly delete it so the statement i'll
write for that is struct
node
star
temp
is equal to
front
now the first condition that will write
in this dequeue function is underflow
error so let's begin with if lock if
front
is equal to equal to null
printf
q
as an empty state
slash n
and return the control to the next
function
otherwise in next case when both front
and rear will be equal we'll set both
these pointers to the null manually so
to do that we'll insert another if lock
if
front
is equal to equal to rear
is equal to rear
is equal to null
this if lock will get activated when
there is only one element inside the
cube in all other cases we can simply
make a front point to the next node so
we'll simply do a front is equal to
front dot next so for that we'll write
else block
else
front
is equal to
dot
next
in all three previous mentioned cases we
are trying to remove elements and that
can only be done by implicit call of
function pre so let's call function free
to delete the front node from our queue
so the statement that we'll write is
front
free
the temporary variable which is actually
storing the head node address
next we'll work on peak operation and
for that we'll create a new function
in
peak
the peak function is used to extract the
value of print pointer for front pointer
we will simply check if the queue is
empty if it is empty then obviously
there is no element at front node to
extract but if it is not empty then we
can extract a value from print pointer
so for that we'll create a if block if
front
is equal to equal to null
which also means the queue is empty
then we'll return
printf
q
is empty
slash n
otherwise we will return
the data present at front node
now we have implemented all important q
functionalities but we won't be able to
check the state of q with the help of
these functions so let's formulate one
more function called as print to
visualize our queue so
let's define this function void
print
inside this function will create a
temporary pointer struct
node
star
temp
is equal to front
we are initializing this temporary
pointer to the front so that we can
traverse the whole q elements using
iterator element so moving forward let's
create this iterator element using a
while block so the statement that will
write for that is while
temp
is not equal to null
printf
modulus d
comma
temp
dot
data
and we will set
temp
is equal to temp dot
next
this is nothing but the traversal of
linked list
now we'll also print f
slash n
so that
all elements will be printed in order
with this we have completed the
implementation of print function as well
now let's work on our driver method
called as main function to contemplate
the output of our program
inside this we'll make call to the
enqueue function nq
and we will print the state of our queue
using print function next we'll make
call nq
and we will also print this state using
print function
next we'll make call to enqueue 6
and we'll also print the state of our
queue at this instance
now after this we'll dequeue few
elements dq
and we'll print the state
next we will encumb one more element and
queue eight
now that we are done with the coding
implementation of queue using linked
list let's execute the program and
visualize the output
this is the output that we have received
let's compare it with the calls that we
have made in order to judge its
correctness
the first call that we made was nq2 so
the print function has printed 2 over
here
after that we inserted 11 4 and 6 and
our friend function has printed the
state after these operations as well
next we deleted the element present at
front pointer which is 2 so after
deleting 2 the output that we got is 4
and 6.
finally we inserted one more element to
check if it is getting inserted at the
rear end and that element was it which
is exactly inserted at the rear end of
cube
introduction to priority queue
primarily we will have a look at the
real-life example of priority queue to
understand it better a hospital
emergency queue is almost an ideal
example of priority queue when you go to
the hospital you must have observed that
the person who needs immediate medical
attention will be treated first
irrespective of his arrival at the
reception that means treating a person
who is in agonizing pain or in emergency
medical condition is the priority of the
queue of patients
priority queue in computer science also
works with same approach
so what exactly is this priority queue
well a priority queue is an abstract
data type that operates similar to the
normal queue except for the fact every
element has certain priority assigned to
it
this definition of priority queue
suggests that this particular type of
queue also follows the same restrictions
for insertion and deletion of data
elements the insertion in the priority
queue will only be achieved at one end
and deletion at another or opposite time
additionally the priority of data
elements will determine the order of
removal the elements which have higher
priority will leave the queue at first
and the elements which has lower
priority will definitely leave the queue
at last
as a side note i would like to tell you
guys that the priority queue only
supports the elements that are
comparable
meaning the data that we are going to
insert into priority queue must be
orderable the compiler should not be
facing any difficulty while comparing
these data elements otherwise the
execution of a priority queue will
definitely fail moving ahead let's have
a look at an example of priority queue
in this priority queue we'll insert 7
2 45 23 and 12 respectively these
elements are not ordered so how the
priority queue is going to store them in
order
well at the time of insertion the
priority queue conducts a comparison of
each element with every other element
present inside a queue to store them in
order but as there is no element inside
a queue so the first insertion that is
an element with value 7 will be attained
followed by that the next element will
be inserted in a queue
since the newly inserted element is
smaller than that of previously inserted
element will swap their positions in
order to maintain order remember the
element with least value will have a
higher order and the element with
greatest value will have a least
priority or order
now we will insert the next element in a
queue that is 45 as 45 is a larger
element than the elements inside the
queue there is no need to shuffle
elements when we make the next insertion
the element 32 will get inserted at
index 3 now this element is smaller than
that of 45 so the algorithm will have to
swap the locations of these 11
now we will perform the final insertion
into our queue we'll insert 12 at index
4 now but as you can see this element is
smaller than both the previous elements
thus the algorithm will have to swap
their positions
now 45 will reach the end of q as it is
the element with highest value and 2
will remain at the front of q as it is
the least valued element
as a humans we could see the numbers
visually inside the priority queue and
further we can easily arrange them but
how does the machine know this does it
restore all the elements inside the
priority queue before each insertion no
obviously that would be highly
ineffective as there will be n
comparisons for insertion of n elements
leading to time complexity big o of n
square
this is an enormous time complexity
which we cannot allow in any software
application we will understand how the
priority queue manages to reduce this
time complexity in upcoming topics
but right now we will contemplate
different properties of a priority queue
that we have learned from previous
example the first property of priority
queue suggests that each element has a
certain priority assigned to it that
priority might depend on value of data
element it can be either larger or
smaller the next property states that
element with higher priority will leave
the queue at first where the element
with least priority will leave the
priority queue at last
further if two elements have the same
priority then the element will be
removed from the priority queue based on
their arrival that means the element
which arrived at first out of the
elements having same priority will be
removed first
now moving ahead will deal with the
representation of priority queue using a
linked list as usage of arrays is not an
ideal way to implement priority queue
if we consider array implementation of
priority queue then inserting items into
the sorted array will cost us big o of n
and in general processing each element
will further cost us big o of n square
as discussed previously so in this
tutorial we'll just look into the link
list representation of priority queue
we will understand the representation of
priority queue with the help of an
example
initially let's say there are three
elements inside a link priority queue
and all of them are in order 3 being the
least element has highest priority where
43 has the least priority the purpose of
keeping 3 at the head node is that we
want our priority queue to delete
elements according to their priority now
we want to insert a new node consisting
of data element 2
and as the data element is smaller than
the element at head node that is 3 so
this new node should be inserted prior
to it this particular scenario of
insertion seems pretty perfect but it
does not cost us more time but what if
the element is significantly larger than
all the nodes in queue for instance
let's say we want to insert 45 as a new
element
in that case primarily it will be
compared with element 2 and as 45 is
larger than 2 our temporary pointer will
move to the next node for comparison
now
45 will be compared with element 3 and
again the temporary pointer will be
moved to the next node for comparison
after two comparisons the temporary
pointer has reached element 17 for
performing the next comparison and here
also 45 is larger than 17 so the
temporary pointer will again move
towards the next node
now finally our temporary pointer has
arrived at the tail node consisting of
element 43 again in this case the
element 45 is larger than 43 thus the
new node will be inserted after node
containing data element 43.
from this specific example of insertion
into a priority queue we can clearly see
that there are n comparisons leading to
the time complexity big of n
where the complexity of deletion remains
constant that is big of one
while understanding the representation
of priority q we came across some packs
that make priority queue implementation
using linked list quite vulnerable
so here we will again try to recall them
the first drawback of priority queue
implementation using linked list is that
it cost us big o of n for inserting a
new element
further it also cost us big o of n for
peak operation
and as memory and time management is the
purpose of data structure hence we must
try to analyze other implementation
strategies
that is why in upcoming slides we'll
look into different approaches to
implement a priority queue
there are three approaches that
implement a priority queue with
complexity less than big op and square
we have already discussed the linked
list so let's also look into other two
approaches
binary heap and binary tree provides
almost similar complexities these
approaches cost us big of log n for
insertion and deletion
and big of one for peak operation but
which one of these operation is most
optimal approach to implement priority
queue
well to answer this question we again
need to discuss about memory management
in the case of both this data structure
you guys know that binary heap data
structure is implemented using arrays
and since it utilizes arrays there is
always a better locality of reference as
well as operations become more cache
apprentice
the binary search tree uses pointer to
implement front and rear node which
definitely takes up more space in memory
due to that building a cell balancing
bst cost us big o of n log n where
binary heap just cost us big o of n
these facts clarify that the binary heap
is the best data structure to implement
a priority queue
now you must be thinking about what
exactly the heap is and how does it work
so moving forward we'll look into the
definition of heap and its properties
basically a heap is a tree based data
structure that satisfies the heap in
variant or in simpler words heap
property the heap invariant states that
if a is a parent node of b then a is
ordered with respect to b for all nodes
a and b in heat
what that means is the value of parent
node is always greater than or equal to
the value of child node in the heap or
other way around the value of parent
node is less than or equal to the value
of child node for all nodes in a heap
further there are two types of heap
named as max heap and minimum heat first
we will look into maxi
the max heap is heap in which value of
parent node is greater than the value of
child node
for this particular example of max heap
you can see that the root node is the
biggest element in tree and each child
node is smaller than its parent node
the next type of heap is minimum heat
the mean heap is heap in which the value
of parent node is less than the value of
child node
in this specific example you can observe
that each child node is larger than its
parent node and the element at the root
node is smallest element of the heap
both the structures that we have
discussed are binary heaps as every node
has only two children in upcoming slides
we will discuss some complex structures
of heap data structure to better
understand how we can judge if a tree
like structure is heap or not
okay so you can see a tree like
structure on your screen and we are
supposed to check whether if it is a
valid heap data structure or not but
actually here i would like you all to
give it a try by yourself you can also
pause this video if you want but here i
will provide you with a short moment to
inspect this structure
all right i can clearly say that this is
not a valid heap data structure as you
can observe the highlighted part is
violating the heap invariant
moving forward let's analyze another
tree-like data structure to consider if
it is a valid heap or not
well yes this is a valid heap because
even though this one is strangely
structured we are free to move around
the visual representation of nodes to
make it organize
now you all must be thinking how we can
do that well we'll understand that
scenario in upcoming slides
now
how about this one is this a valid heap
no right this is not a valid heap this
structure is not even a tree as it forms
a closed cycle and every heap must be a
tree so it's pretty clear that this is
not a valid heap
now
what about this one
is this a valid heap
yes this is a valid heap as it satisfies
the heap invariant that all the child
nodes must be greater than or equal to
or smaller than or equal to its parent
node
now this is the last structure that we
are going to check if it is a valid heap
or not
what you guys think
is this a valid heap
well i think it's pretty clear that this
is not a valid heap but it can be
converted into a heap by making a one
small change
now
if we make 6 as our root node then this
structure will get converted into a
maxie which is absolutely a valid heap
i hope you all are clear with the heap
invariant and how to judge if a given
tree is a valid heap or not
now moving ahead we'll discuss the
different types of priority queue
basically there are two types of
priority queue based on the priority of
elements
if the element with smallest value has
highest priority then that priority
queue is called as min priority queue
and if element with higher value has the
highest priority then that priority q is
known as max priority queue furthermore
it's vividly clear that the mean
priority queue can be implemented with a
minimum heap where the max priority
queue can be implemented using maximum
heap
moving ahead we'll deal with the
operations in priority queue considering
the heap as implementation strategy
the common operations that we can
perform on priority queue are insertion
deletion and peak but there is one more
hidden additional operation
that gets performed during these
operations that operation is called as
heapify hefify manages the priority of
data elements in a heap by shuffling the
data elements after new insertion or
deletion
first of all we will understand how
insertion in priority queue happens with
the help of an example
in this example we are inserting a new
data element that is 43
but due to this insertion the structure
disobeys the priority queue invariant
that the parent node of the max priority
queue must be greater than its child
node
now the hippie pi operation solves this
problem by rearranging data elements by
carrying out the comparison in this
particular case 43 becomes the parent
node where 40 becomes the child node
the next step is deletion
as we know the highest priority element
will be the first to leave the priority
queue and further it is stored at the
root node of a max heap so definitely
the element present at the root node
will get removed
but due to this operation the order of
priority queue gets affected however the
heapify operation comes to the rescue it
reshuffles the elements of the priority
queue to rearrange them in order
the next operation that we are going to
discover is peak
the peak operation simply returns the
element present at root node without
removing it and it is easily accessible
thus the time complexity of this
operation is big of one
i hope you all are clear with the
operations that can be performed on
priority queue moving forward we'll try
to implement them with the help of
minimum heap
as discussed earlier while implementing
a heap data structure we know that all
the elements will get stored in an array
and we don't have any pointers pointing
to either child or parent nodes so how
exactly does the heap data structure
remember nodes like parent nodes and its
left or right nodes
well if you have learnt binary trees
then you must know the formulas present
on your screen these formulas determines
the left child right child or even the
parent node of any binary tree
let's understand how this phenomenon
works with the help of an example will
begin with index 0. if we enter 0 in
this arithmetic expression then we will
get 1 and 2 as output that means the
element at index 1 will be the left
child and element at index 2 will be the
right shell and tree structure will look
like this
now moving ahead let's take an example
of index 1. for index 1 the left child
will be at index 3 and the right child
will be at index 4.
similarly for index 2 the left child
will be at index 5 where the right child
will be at index 6. using these formulas
we'll be implementing heavify and
primary queue operations so note them
down for further reference
now moving further we will visit code
editor to implement priority queue data
structure using c programming language
previously i mentioned that heap is
implemented using arrays so to begin
with heap implementation primarily we
will create a structure consisting of
different variables or objects needed to
implement heap data structure so let's
create a structure struct
keep
consistent
size
and
count variable
end
star
heap
array
which is a dynamic array that we are
creating here
and next we'll also declare a pointer to
heap structure along with size and count
variable in a global scope so let's do
that end
star
heap
comma
size comma
count
we'll create one more variable and
initial
underscore size
to represent the initial size of our
priority queue and let's assign it value
4 for now
okay
now it's time to allocate memory to our
heap array for this purpose we'll create
a new function called heap underscore
init so let's create this function void
heap
underscore init
and inside it will pass an argument
struct
heap
star
h
which is a reference of this structure
that we created previously
okay
in this function let's initialize the
variables that we have created inside
this heap structure
so for that we'll initialize h
arrow operator
count
is equal to zero
similarly
h
arrow operator
size
is equal to
initial
underscore sides
and
h
array
is equal to
end
star
malloc
size of
end
star 4
this statement is just allocating four
integer variables to our heap array
basically our heap array is dynamic data
structure that's why we have to
provide it with dynamic memory using
malloc if you are using c plus plus
programming language to implement this
data structure then you can use new
instead of malloc
moving forward
now we'll work on our condition f
not h
arrow operator
allocates memory to heap array then
printf
error
while allocating
the memory
and
that slash one
next
we will write exit command
okay
with this we have successfully
implemented our heap init function
now moving ahead let's implement heavify
function to move the nodes
for that
we will create a heavify function
void
max underscore
hippify
end
star
data
and
log
count
so all these are required variables to
implement this hippify function that we
have passed in argument for this max
repea by function
now let's create few more variables that
we need
and left
comma
right
comma largest
comma temp
now as discussed earlier left
will be equal to
star
location
in array plus
and
right
will be equal to
left
plus
one
now let's
say largest is equal to loc
and
we'll work on conditions now
f
left
it's greater than or equal to
count
and and
data
left
it's
greater than
data largest
that is
the location we have stored in largest
variable
then
largest is equal to
left
with this block what we are doing is we
are checking if the element at location
left is greater than the element at
recent position and the value at left is
also greater than the value of recent
location if these conditions are true
then we will set the recent location as
left
and here we are getting signal that
there is semicolon missing over here so
we'll add it
okay
now let's work on next condition
now we will check the value at right
position if the recent location is
greater than the right and the value at
right is greater than the largest value
then element at largest will be set to
right so for that we'll write condition
f
write
its
data
count
and and
data
right
it's greater than
data
largest
then
is equal to right
otherwise
if
largest
it's not equal to
location
then
we will store
the data present at location in
temporary variable
and
data
loc
is equal to data
largest
this is a swapping operation that we are
carrying out here and next data
largest
is equal to
and now
we will make recursive call to our
hipfire function
max underscore
if i
data
comma largest
comma count
with this we have successfully completed
our hippify function
now we will work on insertion operation
on priority queue let's call this
function heap underscore push
because we are treating this structure
as heap right
so
in heap insertion is called as push
operation so we'll call it
void
heap underscore push and we'll pass
arguments
struct
heap
star
h
end
value
and inside this function will create few
more
variables and index
and
parent
if you guys remember the initial size
that we have allocated to our array is
16 bytes
you can verify with this statement here
that we are providing 16 byte size to
our heap array
but what if you want to insert elements
more than 4 then what we'll do
well for that we'll need to increase the
size of our heap array so we'll do that
here
for this resize we'll create if
condition
f
h
dot
count
is equal to equal to
h
dot
size
then
h
dot
size
plus equal to
and h
dot
heap
array
is equal to
reallock
h
dot
heap array
size of
end
star
h
dot
sides
basically we are using real lock
function in c
to extend the dynamic memory space for
our heap array and in order to increase
the size we have to increment the size
variable first so that's what we have
done in this statement here
and now once done with this we'll check
if our dynamic memory is getting
allocated or not so for that we'll add
one more if condition inside this if
block so it can be called as nested if
if you guys want
dot
keep array
then
exit
-1
now we will move out of this if block
and we will set index variable
to
h
dot
count
plus plus
basically we are iterating with help of
index variable here so
next
we'll add for condition
for loop
index
to
is equal to
parent
and then set this condition
will make parent node is equal to
index
minus 1
by
2.
this is nothing but the formula that we
have discussed
in previous
part
now
we'll add one more condition inside this
follow f
h
dot
heap array
parent
it's greater than or equal to
value
then
we will
break this for loop
otherwise
h dot
heap array
index
will be equal to
h dot
keep array
parent
now we'll move outside this for loop and
we'll add one more condition
of insertion that is h
dot
heap array
and at
position index
we will
add the value provided by
user using
argument to heap push function
okay with this we have successfully
created our heap push function now we
will move towards the next function
that is
heap underscore delete for that will
create new function heap
underscore delete
and
let's make this function
integer
and we'll pass
struct
heap
start
h as an argument
we will create one more
variable
temp
is equal to
h arrow operator
heap
array
and
inside this will pass
a negating index that means we are using
this temporary variable
to traverse through all list of elements
so for that we'll write
dot dot minus minus
h
arrow operator
count
which will
decrease count one by one
now next we'll add condition f
h
arrow operator
count
it's greater than or equal to
edge
arrow operator
sides
plus
two
and and
h
arrow operator
size
it's also greater than the initial
underscore
size okay
then
what we will do is we will
set
size
to negate itself
by 1
for each action and then
we will
add
h arrow operator
keep
array
is equal to
real lock
h
dot
heap
array
comma
size of
end
star
h
arrow operator
and size
sorry
size
and semicolon
so basically what we are doing here is
we are checking if count is smaller than
the size of heap plus 2 and and the
dynamic size of q is also larger than
initialized size that is 4 then what we
are doing is we are reducing the size
for deleting an element using this
statement
and in next statement we are
reallocating that deleted space
so this is how this ip block works
now moving forward we'll add a condition
to check if memory is getting
allocated or not for that we'll write
condition f
not h
arrow operator
heap array
then
what we'll do is exit
with
minus one
okay
now let's move out of this block
and now
we will
set this removed variable to
h
arrow operator
heap array
and index
0.
so if you guys remember
0 is the index of the highest element in
our maximum heap
what i mean here is the element with
highest value is stored at index 0 for
maxi
now moving forward to delete this
element what we'll do is
we will set
h
dot
heap array
and index 0
is equal to
temporary variable
or pointer that we have created
previously
and
next what we'll do is we'll call max
underscore hippie five function
to
rearrange the structure of our priority
queue which has been shuffled due to
this delete operation now for that we'll
pass arguments
our heap structure
that is heap array
and next
the index which was removed and
the count
variable and we'll
return the remove element
okay with this we have successfully
implemented our delete function
now to understand the order of deletion
in priority queue we will implement one
more function called as mtpq
so let's create this function
and in this function will pass the
reference of heap structure in order to
operate on it so let's pass
the structure
here
star
h
and insert this function
we will create a while loop
h
dot
count
is not equal to
zero
then
printf
modulus d
and
recursive call to
keep
delete function
in which will pass h
now
we are done with this empty pq function
further we will create one more function
to visualize our priority queue
let's call this function
void
heap
underscore display
and inside this will pass
structure
heap
star
h
and
now
we will create one iterator element
and
using that iterator element will create
for loop i is equal to 0
to
i
it's greater than
arrow operator
count
plus plus i
and inside this for loop we will print
the elements present in our queue using
this format
modulus d
and we'll call
heap
array but for that we'll need to call
structure as well
if array and
will pass this
iterator variable into it
okay
and then next we'll get outside this for
loop and we'll print f
this to the next line
using slash n
okay
now we have implemented all the required
function for our priority queue moving
forward we'll work on our driver
function that is main method to
contemplate the result of our program so
for that we'll first call struct
keep edge
then
we'll call
init function to create heap
structure
so heap in it
and we'll pass
the address of
h
next
we will call
heap
underscore push function
to insert
element and h
comma
one
next
i will copy this
part
will paste it to insert another element
now we'll insert five here
next
paste and we'll
pause three
next we'll insert element
next we'll
insert element 9
and after this we'll insert element 8
okay
so now
let's display the elements inside our
key
using heap underscore display function
and let's pause and edge
object
print it and
again
we'll call
mtpq function
empty
pq
and after deleting all elements
it will return the state of our heap
array again or our priority queue so
finally we'll add return zero statement
and now our code is ready so let's
compile it and check it if it works fine
or not
so we are getting four errors here guys
so we'll need to resolve them
first we'll need to check line number 82
so for 82
okay here we haven't added semicolon
so i think this should be fine now still
we have two errors
before i
teach there
so let's recompile it and check it if it
is working fine now
so
we have received our output now now if
you look at our output our output is
printing elements 9 7 8 1 5 and 3 and
deletion of elements is also happening
according to their order so 9 is getting
deleted first after 8 7 5 3 and 1.
so
that means our elements are getting
removed in proper order further we can
say that our program for priority queue
implementation works fine
now if you guys are worried about this
program then not to worry we have you
covered you can mention your email ids
in comment box below and we will send it
over to you remember guys we can make
comments private to protect all your
data so you can fearlessly put all your
email ids in comment box below
now we will discuss applications of
priority queue to understand its
importance
the first application that we are going
to discuss is use of priority queue in
google maps you must have used google
maps several times to navigate from one
city to another or from your location to
nearest desired location have you ever
wondered how google maps managed to do
that how does it provide an optimal path
to reach your location
well ditkastra's shortage path algorithm
implemented in google maps actually
manages to do that by gaining access to
all possible paths this algorithm uses
the priority queue to maintain all the
paths in order let's understand how it
works in detail
now when you provide the location of
place you want to reach via your mobile
device google maps feeds the data of all
possible path to digikestra's algorithm
those paths or road are stored in
minimum priority queue considering the
distance as parameter for priority
assignment and we have learned that the
minimum priority queue maintains the
lowest value at the print or root node
this is how the priority queue helps
google map to search for an ideal path
for reaching destination location
the next application that we are going
to discuss is data compression in winzip
or gzip these applications use hubman
encoding algorithm to reduce the size of
files
hupman coding is a lossless data
compression algorithm and in this
algorithm a variable link code is
assigned to input different characters
the code length is related to how
frequent characters are used most
recurring characters have the smallest
codes and longer codes are for the least
frequent characters this is how the
generated codes will maintain the
complete data while utilizing less
memory space
let's understand how this process works
with the help of an example
let's say our text file contains these
random characters
the hubman encoding algorithm creates
codes for each character based on its
number of occurrences for instance the
frequency of character a is more
prominent than b and character c has
less frequency so the length of code a
is smaller than b and length of code b
will be smaller than c
now according to the amount of generated
code the priority queue will determine
the priority of characters and will
store them these codes takes less size
than the actual characters in memory
space and due to the mapping of
occurrences data does not get lost
i hope now you guys understand why the
priority queue is treated as an abstract
data structure itself and why it is the
better version of queue data structure
what is dq
dq is an abbreviation for double ended
queue and as the term double ended queue
suggests it is a type of queue with some
advanced features at both of its ends
but previously we have learned that the
basic queue data structure must perform
insertion from one of its end and
deletion from another or opposite end
so what new limitation of feature does
this particular type of queue brings
well the dq extends the concept of a
linear queue by implementing insertion
and deletion at both of its nodes by
that what i mean is the dq data
structure is acquainted with the
possibility to insert and delete new
elements at any node that is why dq is
concerned as more generalized version of
queue data structure
now moving ahead we shall understand the
key properties of dq
the first property of dq states that the
dq can use the lipo principle for
inserting or removing elements the last
in first dot principle is used while
implementing stacked data structure and
according to this principle the queue
elements must be inserted from one end
and should also be removed from the same
end
for instance we are storing some
elements inside this queue structure
which is performing both insertion and
deletion from one end
however when deletion begins the element
inserted at last will be removed first
whereas the element stored at first will
get removed at the end this property
clears that the dq can inherit all the
properties of stack data structure
the next property of dq states that the
dq can use the fifo principle for
performing both insertion and deletion
operations
that means the element which enters
inside the queue at beginning will also
leave the queue at first
further the element which entered at
last can leave the queue at last
both of these properties displays the
uniqueness of this particular type of
queue data structure
now in upcoming slides we will
understand different types of the dq
the first type of dq we have is termed
as input restricted queue
this terminology itself suggests that
this particular type of dq will have
some restrictions while performing nq or
insertion operation
in this type of dq the insertion can
only be performed from one end where
deletion can be performed at both of its
ends the representation of dq shown
below explains how the operations in
this type of dq will get accomplished
the next type of dq is output restricted
dq
this term makes clear that this type of
queue will have some restrictions while
performing deletion operations
in this specific type of queue the
removal of elements can only be
performed from 1 8 where the insertion
can be performed at both of its eights
this particular structure of a queue
explains how the different operations
will take place in this type of dq
now here is the interesting question
that we want you all to answer
based on the properties of dq that we
have discussed till now which of the
following data structure will be more
ideal for implementing dq in data
structure what i mean by ideal is the
time and space complexity for
implementation strategy that you decide
should be minimum
the options that we have are
circular array
singly linked list and doubly linked
list
it will be interesting to see how many
of you guys will get this right
so guys do leave your answers to this
question in comment section below in a
week's time we'll be announcing the
right answer and you all can check it
out
on that note let's dive further and
understand the representation of dq
using circular queue and yes
circular queue is one of the answers for
previous questions we'll understand why
it is best in upcoming slides but please
check the complexity analysis of other
two strategies to decide your answer for
the previous question as multiple
answers can be accurate for that
question
now let's understand what a circular
queue is
well a circular queue is nothing but the
extended notion of linear q as it
follows the first in first out principle
with the exception that the last
position of this particular queue is
connected to its first position making a
circular link
this circular link is responsible for
naming of this queue as circular queue
or ring buffer let's understand how a
circular queue operates with the help of
simulation
this is the illustration of a circular
queue having size 5 as the position of
rear pointer keeps increasing a new
element will be inserted in this queue
until the rear pointer reaches the end
of q
but what if we perform dq operation now
if we perform the deletion then the
empty space will get created at front of
queue however this space can further be
utilized in this particular type of
queue by making circular incrementation
of rear pointer or circular link
so if we increment the rear pointer from
its index 5 to index 0 we can utilize
empty space by making new insertions
using this feature of circular queue we
can implement both insertion and
deletion at both the ends of queue
let's understand how we can do that in
upcoming slides
the first type of insertion is a pretty
ordinary one in this insertion we'll
increment the position of rear pointer
to insert a new element the arrow shown
in blue is rear pointer and the arrow
shown in orange is the front pointer so
as you can see once we increment the
rear pointer new elements get inserted
this is how the insertion using rear
node happens
now what if we want to perform insertion
using front end in order to perform the
insertion using front node we'll have to
make front pointer reach to the end of q
the only possible way to achieve that is
to set front pointer equal to max size
-1 manually
this command will allow a front pointer
to reach the end of queue for performing
insertion and for further insertions
we'll just have to decrement the front
pointer location for inserting new
elements this is all about insertion
now that we have implemented insertion
from both ends let's move on to the
deletion operation
primarily we'll look into the deletion
using front node in order to delete
elements using front node we'll have to
increment the front pointer until it
reaches the end of q and once it reaches
the max size we'll use circular
incrementation to bring the front
pointer to the beginning of queue while
performing these incrementation
meanwhile the elements will be removed
from the queue
next up is deletion using rear end for
performing deletion using a rear pointer
we'll have to decrement its location
once we decrement the rear pointer
location the element will get removed
from the queue
now moving ahead we'll look into the
different operations that can be
performed on a double ended queue
basically there are four primary
operations in the dq which we have
already understood in the representation
of dq using circular queue
these operations are insertion and
deletion at the front and insertion and
deletion at the rear
additionally the circular queue
implementation of dq cost us big of 1
which is the most optimal complexity
that we can hope for
having said that let's dive into the
implementation of these operations using
a circular queue
we'll implement a double ended queue
using circular queue in order to do that
we'll use c programming language and one
dimensional arrays so without wasting
any time further let's move to the code
editor
now in order to get started with
implementation of dq we'll have to
create array and pointer variables so
let's do that
and
we'll name this array as dq
and we'll provide 100 as initial size
next we'll create pointers
and
rear
is equal to minus 1
now we'll also define the maximum size
for our queue using define call
size
as 5.
after done with this initialization
process we'll start working on insertion
from front node we'll declare a function
named as voidfront insert so let's do
that void
front
underscore
insert
and instead this function will pass an
argument into z to insert an element
now while performing insertion we should
always check if the queue is full or not
because if it is full then the insertion
won't be possible so for that we'll
write condition
if
front
is equal to equal to zero
and and
rear
it's equal to equal to size
minus 1
inside
and braces
or
front
is equal to equal to rhea
plus 1
printf
dq
as
full
insertion
it's not possible
okay
otherwise if both the front and rear
node are pointing to null memory index
or -1 will manually set up front pointer
to index 0 to make the first insertion
into the queue
and we will insert the element at new
location or index 0 where the front
pointer is pointing so for that
what we'll do is we'll write another
condition with lc block
else f
front
is equal to equal to
minus 1
and and
rear
is equal to equal to minus 1
then
make front
is equal to rhea is equal to
and
dq
front
is equal to
z
now if we want to insert the element at
the last node of q then we need to set
front pointer to the max size -1
location to do that we'll write this
condition else
if
front
is equal to equal to zero
then
front
is equal to
size
minus 1
and dq
front
is equal to z
if all these above mentioned conditions
fail then the front pointer is already
at the last part of q
and it just need to decrement its
location for inserting element in empty
spaces as discussed previously so to do
that we'll write one more condition
using else block
so let's do that
else
front
is equal to front
minus 1
and dq
front
is equal to z
now we have successfully implemented a
front insert function so let's move
forward and work on another function
that is called as void
rear
underscore insert
and we'll pass g as an argument to
insert an element
now as done previously we will first
check if our queue is full or not so
let's do that using if condition
f
front
is equal to equal to zero
and and
rear
is equal to equal to size minus 1
inside braces
or
front
is equal to equal
equal to equal to
rear
plus 1
then
printf
dq
is full
next if there is no element in an array
we'll manually set the rear pointer to
index 0 for new insertion so for that
we'll write condition else f
front
is equal to equal to minus one
and and
rear
it's equal to equal to minus one
then set rear
is equal to 0
and
insert
dq
ria
is equal to z
otherwise if rear pointer is already at
the end of q then we will bring it to
the beginning of q so for that we'll
write condition else f
rear
is equal to equal to size
minus one
then
being
rear
to index zero
and dq
rear
is
equal to
z
if all these mentioned conditions fail
then what we'll do is we'll write else
condition and we'll simply increment our
rear pointer to make an insertion so for
that what we'll do is we'll create else
block and we're inside it
we will
do rear plus plus
and we will set dq
rear
is equal to c
with this we have successfully
implemented void rear insert function so
now let's move into deletion functions
first we'll create void front dq
function void
front
underscore dq
and there is no need for any argument
for this function
to begin with this function first we'll
have to check if dq is empty because we
cannot delete elements if there is no
element to delete so for that we'll
write f condition if
front
it's equal to equal to minus one
and and
rear
is equal to equal to minus one
then
printf
there is no element
to
delete
inside
this
dq
in the next condition we'll check if
there is only one element inside the dq
if there is only one element then we'll
set both front and rear to minus one
manually for that what we'll do is we'll
create else if condition
else if front
is equal to equal to rhea
then
printf
let slashing to take this to the next
line
the
deleted
element
from
the front
is
modulus d
comma
dq
front
and we will set front
is equal to minus 1
similarly
ria
is equal to minus 1.
now if both these above mentioned
conditions fail then we will delete the
element from our front node
the first removal will be in a case when
the front pointer is at the end of q so
for that we'll write condition else if
front
is at end of q that is size
minus 1
and what we'll do is
we will printf
slash and
the
deleted
element
from
the front
it's
modulus
day
comma dq
front
comma
and another condition will be when the
front pointer is at the beginning
section of a cube for that
we'll write else condition
printf
slash n
the deleted
element
from
the front is
modulus d
comma dq
front
with this we have successfully
implemented our front dq function now
let's move towards next function that is
deletion from the rear end for that
we'll create new function name
void dq
underscore rear
and this function also does not need any
argument so next
what we'll do is we'll create
condition to check if the queue is empty
or not
so
if front
is equal to equal to minus 1
and and
rear
is equal to equal to -1
then
printf
slash n
there is no element
to
[Music]
delete inside the queue
now let's move to the next condition
in next condition i'll write else if
front
is equal to equal to rhea
then
printf
some
statement and
set
run
is equal to -1
along with ria is equal to
-1
and that statement will be
the
deleted
element
from
the dq
using
rear
node
as
modulus d
comma
dq
area
now
if both these above mentioned conditions
fail
then we'll have to delete the element
from our real node the first removal
will be in a case when rear is at the
beginning portion of a queue for that
let's write a condition
else f
rear
is equal to equal to 0 that is at the
beginning part of q
then
printf
some statement
and
rear
is equal to size minus 1 that is setting
it to the max size of cube
and the statement that we will return is
backslash n
the deleted
element
from
the rear
node
as
modulus d
comma
dq
rear
in other cases we'll just have to
decrement the size of rear pointer and
delete the element so for that we'll
write else condition
printf
some statement
and
set rear
is equal to rear
minus
1 that is decrementing the size of rear
pointer and the statement that we'll
write as backslash n
the
deleted
element
from
the rear
node
as modulus d
and comma
dq
rear
well here is one spelling mistake so
let's remove it
okay
so with this we have successfully
implemented our void dq rear function
now we will implement one more function
to display the state of our
dq
the name of that function will be void
display
and this function also does not need any
argument so we'll begin with
implementation of this function for this
we'll create an iterator element and
we'll set it to the front
pointer
and we'll printf
backslash n
elements
inside
the
dub
double
ended
queue
are
next line
will enter into while loop to print
those element
i
not equal to
rear
printf
modulus
d
comma
dq
i
and
will increase the value of i
by
i
plus one
modulus
size
and outside this while loop we will
print f
modulus d
dq
rhea
okay
with this we have implemented all the
required functionalities for our dq so
let's work on driver method that is main
function
in order to check the output of our
program so
let's work on this main function
first we will insert
few elements into our queue so i will
insert first element using front insert
next
let's insert one more element from front
node
using function front insert
and this element will be 23
next we will insert elements using rear
node
underscore insert
and we'll pass 17 now
next we'll insert
and
we'll insert one more element using this
rear node only
insert
now we will display
the state of our queue after performing
all these operations
and next we will
dq
few elements
so for that we'll
use front dq function
and next
we will dequeue
from
real node
so
dq here
and after performing deletion operations
will also display the state of our queue
so let's call display once again
and let's add one more command
return
zero
okay so with this we have successfully
implemented our program
for dq implementation so let's run it
and check if it is working fine or not
okay so we are getting output here but
display function is printing output in
weird manner so let's
work it out
so all we have to do is we'll have to
add space before modulus t here and here
as well
so
once done with this let's
recompile our code
okay
so now our output is clear so let's
check if it is
perfect or not
so
the first insertion that we made was -5
second was 23 from the front end so
5 should be getting inserted before 23
so minus 5 is getting inserted before 23
but as we are inserting it using front
pointer so 23 is remaining at the front
now after these two insertions we are
performing insertions using rear pointer
the first rear insertion was 17 then 12
then 47 and these elements are getting
inserted
so let me show you how they are getting
inserted in exact same order
so
look here so elements inside the double
ended q are 23 minus 5 17 12 and 47 that
means the insertion is in right order
after that we deleted the element from
front node so the front node is at 23 so
23 is getting deleted after that we
deleted the element using rear node so
47 is getting deleted from the
rear node
we are still getting 23 here that means
the dq function is incomplete so we'll
have to change it so let's go to the dq
function
and i guess it was from
front end so we'll need to change code
for our front dq
so
okay so in this case we haven't brought
our trend pointer
to index 0 so let's do that here and
once we do this let's
recompile our code again
okay so now you can see that the 23 is
getting deleted
with this we have successfully
implemented our dq function
now let's move back to the powerpoint
and understand few applications of dq
the first application that we are going
to discuss in detail is palindrome
checker you all must have heard about
the term palindrome
the palindrome is a specific word or
number which reads the same backward as
forward for example the word radar it
reads the same from both the ends so
using the dq we can implement the
palindrome checker program with
complexity big of 1.
the string which you need to check will
be inserted into a dq and after that it
will read from both sides if the reading
is the same then that string will be
considered as palindrome
the next application of dq is its use in
multiprocessor scheduling
but what precisely is multiprocessor
scheduling and why do we need it
well the system implemented in the old
days use single processor scheduling to
manage the computing processes when
multiple processes need to be executed
by a single core or cpu then the process
take more time to implement and thus the
system lacks computing power
but the multi-processor scheduling
implemented in modern computers resolves
that problem using a double ended queue
suppose we have three processors in our
system and each processor has some
processors to execute each processor
maintains a dq that contains threads
that are ready to execute the processor
executes a process and if a process
creates a child process then that
process will be inserted at the front of
the dq or parent process suppose the
processor p2 has completed the execution
of all its threads then it steals the
thread from the rear end of processor p1
and adds it to the front end of the
processor p2 the processor p2 will take
the thread from front end therefore the
deletion takes from both the ends
this is also known as a still algorithm
in process scheduling in this session we
will learn about stacks and queues in
data structures
what is a stack
so to define stack in a more generalized
way we can consider stack as a linear
data structure that follows lifo order
or lost in first out order or another
way of putting it down is first come
last out order
so some of the basic operations that can
be performed on stack are insertion and
deletion and that can be done only at
the end which is called as the top of
the stack
now let us understand the basic
operations on stack so the three
fundamental operations that can be
applied onto a data structure like stack
r
push pop and peak so the push operation
involves inserting a new element from
the top of the stack the pop operation
involves removing the element from the
top of the stack and finally the peak
operation which returns the topmost
element from the stack without removing
the element from the stack
now we shall go through some generalized
examples of stack
so some of the generalized examples of
stack are you can see a stack of books
here and a stack of utensils stack of
coins and stack of dollars of bills
now let us go through a practical
example based on stack and data
structures we shall be using c
programming language for this particular
example
so you can see that on my screen i have
an example for stack data structure
don't worry about the code this code
will be attached in the description box
below and you can always have access to
it and you can run the same code in your
personal system so that you have a
deeper and better understanding of the
program now let's quickly run this
program
so there you go you can see the program
is getting executed now
so you can see that the program got
successfully executed and the elements
are being inserted into the stack
now the elements are a b
and finally the elements are popped back
again that is b a and the last element
that is popped away from the stack is a
and you can see that the stack is
currently empty so top is pointing to -1
now with that let's get back to the
presentation again
now let us understand some of the
applications of stack
so one of the applications of stack is
function call or recursion the recursive
function call is also known as the
called stack whenever a function is
called then the function goes to the top
of the stack
now another important application of
stack is expression conversion there are
three types of notations that is prefix
notation infacionation and postfix
notation so these particular notations
can be taken care by using stacks in
real time
now the next one is checking parentheses
stack is used to check if the given
parenthesis are balanced or not
sometimes if you forget to add a
parenthesis then the compiler will throw
an error so using stack this can be
found if there are balanced parenthesis
used in your program or not balanced
parenthesis means opening and closing
brackets are of the same type that means
if you have two open flower brackets
then you need to have two closed flower
brackets it should not be an equal it
should be completely equal to complete
the code segment
now another application of stack is
expression evaluation stack can be used
to evaluate the expressions as you can
see here we have an expression that is 6
plus 2 star 3 minus 12 divided by 4.
now this particular expression will be
evaluated based on the presidency table
so the stack is used to check the
precedence and then the expression gets
evaluated into the result which is 21
right over here
now another application is the tower of
hanoi tower of hanoi is a mathematical
puzzle which consists of three rods and
n number of discs of different diameters
all the discs are placed on one rod one
over the other and in ascending order of
size similarly into a cone-shaped tower
now we will enter into the next segment
where we will discuss about queues so
what exactly is a queue a queue is a
linear data structure
that follows the fifo order that is the
first and first out
whereas stack followed first in last out
so this is one of the fundamental
difference between stacks and queues so
we'll be discussing those in the next
section for now let's continue with the
operations on queue the queue is an
ordered list in which insertion is done
at one end that is called rear and
deletion is done at another end which is
called front the operations on qr nq
operation that adds a new item to the
queue if the queue is complete then
there is an overflow condition
dq operation is the operation which
deletes an item from the queue and if
the queue is empty then there is an
underflow condition through as an
exception
now let us understand some of the
basic examples of queue you can consider
the patients at hospital registration
and you can also consider an example of
customers making use of atm
now let us understand the types of queue
so there are basically three types of
queues those are circular queues doubly
ended queues and priority queues
now let us understand the circular queue
in a circular queue the last element
points to the first element to form a
circular link
circular queue is also known as ring
buffer insertion is done at the rear and
deletion is done at the front as
discussed before
now we will go through the doubly ended
queue in doubly ended queue both
insertion and deletion can be done at
both rear and front of the queue
now the last one the priority queue in
the priority queue the notes have same
predefined priority insertion can be
done as the arrival of the notes node
having the least priority will be the
first node removed from the key now we
will go through a general practical
example of queues and then we will go
through the applications of queues now
on my screen you can see an example for
queues don't worry about the code this
code will be attached in the description
box below and you can always have access
to it and learn executing this on your
own system so without further ado let's
start to execute this code
so you can see that the code got
successfully executed and the terminal
is asking for us to give an operation so
the first one is to insert an element
into the queue second one is to delete
an element and the third one is to
display the elements in the queue and
the fourth one is to quote let's insert
so now let us insert an element into the
queue that is 10.
now let's try to display the elements in
the queue for that i need to select the
option number three
and there you go the queue has element
number 10. now let's try to delete that
element for that we might have to choose
the second option
so you can see that the element got
deleted from the queue and the element
deleted from the queue is 10
and
you have another choice now so
let's try to quit it now so that i need
to select the option for because we have
seen how to insert view and delete the
element
let's not make further delay and let's
quickly enter into the next part of our
session that is the application of
queues
so the first application of queue is
breadth first search
breadth first search or bfs traverses a
graph in a breadthward direction and
uses a queue to remember the next node
to start a search
the second application is level order
traversal entry level order traversal
processes all the nodes of a tree by
depth first the root then the children
of the source
next one is first come first serve cpu
scheduling first come first serve fcfs
is an operating system algorithm that
works on cued requests and implements
them according to their arrival
now the fibonacci
fibonacci heap is a data structure that
implements priority queue operations
consisting of the collection of heap
order trees
now our last segment that is the
comparison between stack and queue
so at first both stack and queue are
linear data structures and stack follows
last in first out whereas q follows
first in and first out
and when you are considering stack the
insertion takes place at the top
and deletion takes place from the top as
well
whereas when it comes to stack the
insertion starts from rear but deletion
or elimination of the element from the
queue starts from the front
in stacks the insert operation is called
as push
and deletion process is called as pop
in queues the insertion is called as
enqueue and deletion is called as dq
in stacks we mainly maintain one pointer
to access the list that is called top
which always points to the last element
present in the list in queues we
maintain two different pointers the
first one is the front pointer which
always points to the front element or
the first element inserted in the list
and the next one is the rare pointer
which always points to the rare or the
last element inserted into the list
stack is used in solving problems that
work on recursion whereas q is used in
solving problems having sequential
processing so these are the fundamental
differences between stacks and queues in
this session we will learn about linear
social algorithm its complete logic and
how to program and implement it in real
time now let us try to understand what
exactly is searching
searching in data structure refers to
the process of finding the desired
element in the set of items the selected
item is called the target element any
data structure such as an array linked
list tree or graph can be used for
searching a set of elements
in data structures searching can be
categorized into two types first type is
the sequential search in which we check
the elements in a data list or an array
one by one
in data structures searching can be
categorized into two ways the first type
is a sequential search in which we check
the elements in a data list or an array
one by one
an example for sequential search is
linear search
now let us learn about the next type of
searching approach the next type of
searching approach is the interval
search approach
interval search divides the search in
half by repeatedly targeting the center
of the data set the binary search
algorithm can be an example for interval
search
we will go over the binary search
algorithm in detail in our upcoming
video
after understanding the logic of search
and the types of search we will get into
understanding what is linear search
algorithm
the linear search method is a simple
search technique in this type of
searching approach we perform a
sequential search across all objects one
after the other every element is
examined and if there is a match found
then the specific element is returned
otherwise the search will continue until
the data gathering is complete
let us go through an example for better
learning experience on my screen we have
the following elements 50 10 20 30 70 40
90 60 as randomly distributed elements
let us imagine that our target element
is 70.
we found that our target element was 70
using linear search strategy so how does
it work in the next segment we will look
into the working terms of linear search
algorithm the simplest method of
searching the data collection is the
linear search starting from the
beginning of the data set each element
is examined until no match is found the
linear search is completed after the
item has located
in the first stage we compare the first
element that is 50 to the searched
element that is 70. we will go on to the
next element because 50 and 70 are not
matched
we will compare the second element which
is 10 to the search element that is 70
in the next step
and once more there is no match found
then we have the element 30 as the next
comparison and 70 and 30 are not matched
we have the next element that is 20 in
the fourth phase and there is no match
when we compare 20 with 70.
moving on to the following stage we have
the data element 70 and after comparing
70 with the search element there is a
match we will now have the searching and
display index as 4 and this index
contains the searched element
we now comprehend the pseudo code of the
linear search algorithm after learning
the working terminology of linear search
algorithm
first we have a function called linear
search which has two variables in its
parameters the arrays name which is an
array and the search variable which is
the value then using a follow we must
search for our target variable by
analyzing all the data elements in the
data set with the condition that is the
search item is identical to any set's
value we must return its index value
now we must stop searching once the
searched value has been discovered
then we will close our if and for loop
as well as the linear search function
we will now look into the complexity of
linear search algorithm after
comprehending the pseudo code
the complexity of linear search
algorithm is divided into three
categories the best case which is the
big o of one the average case which is
the big o of capital n and the worst
case scenario which is same as the
average case which is the big o of n
here n is the number of data items to be
sorted let us look into how all these
complexities of linear search algorithm
play out in detail
first we have the best case which is big
o of n as a result the best case
scenario happens when the searched
element is found in the data sets first
block
as a result the search takes a constant
amount of time
here is an example of an array with 50
10 40 20 30 as the elements
now our search element is 50 which is
located in the first location of the
array then there's the typical case of
linear such algorithm which has big o of
n and occurs when the search element is
in the middle of the data set or any
point of the data set with the array
containing the same search element 50 we
can easily see that the element 50 is
present in the center of the array at
the location number 2. finally we have
the worst case which is big o of n which
is same as that of the average case of
the linear search algorithm and happens
when the search element is in the last
block of the data set
as a result of the number of searches
required is proportional to the number
of elements as demonstrated in this
example the search element 50 is found
in the last block of the array index
which is 4.
in the next segment we will look into
some real-world instances of linear
search algorithms according to the first
application of the linear search
algorithm linear search is particularly
efficient when it comes to discovering a
particular string next we will look into
the second application of linear search
algorithm
when a data set has only few elements
linear search is the simplest to
implement
the final real world application of the
linear search algorithm is with the help
of telephone directory you may find out
the name of a person
with the phone number one two three
this can be implemented easily using
linear search algorithm now let us have
a look at the linear search algorithm
working in practical demonstration
so on my screen we have an example for
linear search algorithm we have included
three libraries standard input output
standard library and console input
output library
then we have entered the main function
where we have declared an array with
maximum size of 50 elements a counter
variable i a variable named target where
we would store our searched element and
finally num variable where the number of
elements in the array is recorded then
we have a printf function to ask the
user how many items are there in the
array and then we use a scanf function
to allow input from the keyboard so we
have added percentage d format specifier
to the scanf function which is used for
numeric values and num variable then
using a for loop we will try to print
all the items in the array starting with
0 and ending with num variable which is
the last element then we will enter our
search element which we want to find
among all the elements of the array and
as previously said we'll store the found
element in the target variable
following that we will use the for loop
to examine all the elements in the array
then we use the if statement to check
for the element is identical to our
searched element or not
if the element is found we exit the
follow and we will break the keyword
and if the target values location is
less than the number of elements in the
array then we will return the location
otherwise if the value location is
greater than the number of elements in
the array then the search will be
unsuccessful and we won't be able to
find the searched element
now we will compile this code and see
the output
so there you go the code got
successfully compiled now it is asking
for the number of elements in the array
let me give us five elements now let's
enter the elements into the array let us
enter some random
elements now we have entered the 5
elements let me provide the searched
element as 2.
now we have found the target element to
be found in the location 2
that is 0 1 and 2 yeah 2 is located in
the second index location
now with that we have come to an end of
this data structures part 1 tutorial if
you have any queries regarding any of
the topics covered in this particular
session or if you need the code executed
in this particular tutorial for any of
the topics then please feel free to let
us know in the comment section below and
our team of experts will be happy to
resolve all your queries and also mail
you all the quotes you need until next
time thank you stay safe and keep
learning